but tim dillon fresh off a covet test
how you feeling buddy how's the nose
feeling good you know when i go out with
friends
uh to restaurants in la they you know
everybody gets the gun
the temperature gun in your head but you
know what's [ __ ] up a lot of my
friends they don't do they do it to me
and i'm like i guess i'm the only one
that looks sick because they look at me
and they go get him get him
and then i ask other people i'm like
were you hit on the way in they're like
no
so i'm like yeah it's weird it's like
arbitrary the way they do
everybody i know maybe they think like
you're a little bit overweight
yeah you could die they're like we don't
want him dying at boa's steakhouse
in west hollywood oh you could eat i
didn't want me falling on a tick tocker
beau is an outside place all outside out
there all outside oh
yes those outside places are they're
they're doing good they're
jammed but the [ __ ] inside places are
doomed they are doomed and they will not
reopen
many of them a lot of them yeah yeah
it's a big problem let me ask you this
when do you think los angeles is going
to open up back up again
next spring wow
like april well i mean it depends what
the second wave does
right if there is a second wave right
does do we get clobbered
in the fall or do it i mean by the time
la reopens it's going to be terminator
here
don't you think that it's going to be
terminator after november no matter what
we do
probably i feel like with all of the
[ __ ] tension
like there was a story in chicago right
they thought it was a 15 year old girl
was shot by the police it turned out to
be a 20 year old man
and he was shot but he was still alive
how did they get that wrong
the [ __ ] telephone game right you
know that game yeah it doesn't work
it's crazy so then everybody goes crazy
and goes looting so like people are
looking for an excuse to go crazy
if there's trump wins again yeah it's
gonna burn not only that it's like yeah
it's gonna be the mail-in thing right
are they gonna take
days 100 wow yeah so it's going to take
days i mean i
assume they're going to have some polls
open some places and we're not going to
know
we're not going to have an answer that
night no that's going to be a fun week
of not knowing who the president is
remember when it happened in 2000
no one cared it was funny yeah that we
didn't have a president
like there was all those snl skits and
you know everybody's making fun of it
there was no real unrest no in 2000
but now we cannot handle the uncertainty
of not knowing we need to know that
night yeah the dangling chads thing it's
no big deal yeah it was funny
everybody was wondering everyone was
like what what what are we doing
laughing
off we were all going we don't need a
president yeah whatever we were so much
more emotionally healthy as a country at
that moment than we are now
yeah this is funny but it is true yeah
because we laughed we go yeah who cares
yeah they go we're fine and but now it's
like
chaos and we need a break like we need a
break
whoever like everybody can't be a
political pundit
like my aunt cannot be writing about
trade
on facebook i think we just leave it all
to alyssa milano
yeah looking forward to her tweets in
november i'm just gonna follow all that
yeah yeah well she was like
she's got a podcast we know that she's
fine yeah
i mean it's relevance right they're all
trying to be relevant everybody's
relevant
like they have to be you have to get
your opinion out there it's super
important
and that's the way to be relevant now is
to just be
you know like be political all day every
day
when you go from actor to activist yeah
all in
very interesting as soon as the [ __ ]
calls stop coming in you're like all
right i'm an activist
what's so funny is we know because we're
like in in this thing
that getting good at this whether it's
comedy or being an actor is very tough
you're not spending your life thinking
about other people let's just be real
for the most part
you're just not i didn't you're thinking
about your career yeah you're thinking
about your career i've spent the last
decade
thinking about myself my jokes how do i
get ahead
how do i get ahead how do i get on
television for
three minutes like so this idea that
these people are now going to pretend
that they've spent their entire career
thinking about global warming
it's just not true like i know these
people like i've met these people oh
yeah
and and my friends have opened for some
of these people and i know that like
these people are going out there and
they're like you know listen we got to
do this we got to do that they got to
move the country forward but i've seen
them
make people cry backstage at a theater
because there's not enough water in the
dressing room right
so it's those same people yeah that are
really cruel
going out and telling everybody how good
of a person they are
all the time well they find the pattern
they find the pattern the
the way they have to talk and the things
they have to talk about when they lock
into those things
with no deviation they find whatever the
line is where hollywood wants whatever
the line is always left
yes it's always super progressive always
super woke and they [ __ ]
ride that line yeah like a [ __ ]
railroad train just choo
choo straight down no deviation it's so
obvious
i know dudes i used to do open mics with
who like they're tweeting it
mayor garcetti they're tweeting
about the budget in l.a
they're like the budget's being passed
they're tweeting garcet
the budget i'm like god you can't you
don't have
the money to pay your rent like you have
no idea what's going on in the world
and you're tweeting at garcetti about
them and they're doing it so that they
can get a job
right they're doing it so that somebody
can see him and go you know what
he'd be you know he'd had a great
garcetti tweet he should write on bojack
horseman
that's the way it works it does kind of
work like that
i've i've i've just i've never been more
amused
it's very funny but i'm also terrified
it's very we're gonna die it has both of
those things
happening it's like part of me is
laughing at how stereotypical everybody
is
and how cliche yeah but then part of me
is like this is
terrifying like the the people at each
other's throats
people are enemies now like listen
people never loved each other because
it's a competitive business but like
i i know like people it wasn't nearly as
intense right as it is right now like
the feeling of like
if you disagree with somebody they are
your enemy
in comedy and they want you to not have
a job like
and i've never felt that way about
anybody i don't care what you
if you're funny i truly don't care
if you're a communist if you're out
whatever whatever you are
you're not you don't have any power it's
not like you're affecting my life
you can believe whatever you want if
you're funny you're funny i don't like
to say this in generalizations because i
don't think i don't believe in
generalizations but
right i love them i do too they're fun i
need them they're they're the best for
college yeah i mean we need them
without generalizations comedy kind of
stuff yeah but
more people on the left are doing this
than people on the right
yeah i don't see that many people on the
right i see a few
but i don't see as many people on the
right calling for people to get canceled
forever
but the people on the left are like burn
their house burn them to the ground
well the right will do it the right i
mean the q anon thing's kind of a way
they're doing it where they're like
david spade's got an ankle bracing on
and
he's in jail and trump's put everyone
under house arrest
like they're in this other thing where
it's like oh you guys have left the
planet
and you like so explained to people who
don't know
what this q and change well the q and
stuff is like there is this idea that
there's an intelligence dissemination
operation happening meaning
behind the scenes high-level
intelligence guys or military people
are leaking information about a shadow
war that we don't really see happening
and the shadow war involves trump and
the people on the side of lightness
battling the you know these deep state
pedophile
pedophile cannibals like i don't know
why like i don't never understood why
they have to be cannibals
i didn't know they were cannibals
they're no they're cannibals they're
eating children and then they get the
adrenal chroma it keeps them young
oh that's right so this whole thing and
then trump is going to war with all of
them
right now listen pedophilia is a big
problem they do
cover up [ __ ] at high levels 100 yes the
epstein stuff is 100
real 100 clinton's on that plane he's on
that island
26 times yeah the franklin scandal
there's scandals all over the world so
i'm not delegitimizing like
the idea of real human trafficking but
the idea
that donald trump is fighting human
traffickers
and the human traffickers are ellen who
is a little wild
that everyone in hollywood's eating
children and there's tunnels under
central paul i mean
it's hard to keep up with and the queue
drops so to speak are like these
these um you know they're like they're
like poems or they're
they're coded information so it's never
like hey this is what
you get these drops where do you get a
4chan or something you get them like
unfortunately okay but 4chan is the best
place in the world
for trolls you know it's a lot of fun
well that's what maybe this is this
could be like
that's what i'm saying yeah it could be
a high-level troll nobody knows because
it's bait it has
nuggets of truth right right just like
anything else right it has nuggets of
very real things the government is shady
as [ __ ]
a lot of the elites are doing things
engaging in pedophilia
and probably worse yeah like i some of
those kids on epstein's island probably
did disappear
but the idea that like that that trump
is fighting this underground war and
it's all about human trafficking i just
don't think
that's borne out by the facts like
there's no facts
to point i mean trump was like friends
with the clintons for his whole life
well not only that if trump was doing it
and not talking about it it would be
so character like imagine this one thing
that he's doing that's the most noble
thing
that he's ever done ever right he's not
selfless
the most important the moment for
humanity and he's not even bringing it
up he's just secretly winking
yeah all the cue people well you know
and and so everything he does there's
like a reason that he does it they say
like when he wishes lane maxwell he goes
i wish her well
yeah now the thing is that's a rich guy
who's forgetting he's the president
who's just on a t at mar-a-lago because
that's how rich people talk
i mean that's literally and i've been
around a few like really wealthy people
this is how they talk when you say
something bad anything bad if you go
you know you know john's wife has cancer
you know that kid had a dewy he's got a
problem he had a couple incidents there
at harvard
they go like this guy i wish him well
tee off
that's that's how they talk that's how
they it's just a dismissal
it's a way to dismiss it but the q
people are like oh there's a meaning
there's hidden meaning right he's saying
that she's and if you look at
ivanka's wearing this dress and it means
and it's just like
listen i'm a conspiracy guy but this is
exhausting well
i don't think he's too much jacket the
jacket
yeah i don't care do you yeah isn't that
what it said yeah i don't care i don't
really care to you
right what yeah i mean it's weird [ __ ]
is this yeah these are weird things what
are we doing so i think the trump
administration
feeds the trolls like i think they like
it i think he'll by the time the
election rolls around he'll be like full
full cue just leaning in who's who's
behind the scenes pulling the strings is
it ivanka
they say jared kushner has a lot of
power but wouldn't be funny if it was
ivanka doing the whole thing
she's the one like stroking her chin
like she's the boss what is the nugget
we release next
right she's q a she's the smart one
who's like
how do we how do we yeah she's the
pretty daughter
everybody dismisses her i mean nobody
takes nobody's right
right she's in the background on the
whole [ __ ] show she's cute
black leather gloves on yeah that go to
the elbow
like the inspector gadget hand you just
see your hand typing on 4chan
send send yeah i don't i don't know man
you know steve bannon said something and
there was a documentary
about errol uh aaron morris made a
documentary about steve bannon he bannon
said this very interesting thing
he said you know there's a guy uh out
there who's got a horrible life like
he's divorced his kids don't like him he
has a shitty job
but when he plays like league of league
of legends or world of warcraft one of
these games
he's a hero and when he dies in real
life nobody really cares but when he
dies in the game
so many people come out and they like
you know they show him respect because
you're playing with people from all over
the world
so bannon's like which which life is the
real life
so which of course it's the real one
that you're living not this fantasy game
but i think the q anon thing i think the
trump administration is like yeah let
people believe
they're hunting pedophiles online it
gives their lives meaning
like let these people believe they're
like hunting the clintons it's like fun
it's like a fun video game for them and
then they don't have to ask why they
don't have health insurance and can't
get a knee operation
i don't think that it's that involved
i think it's just a thing that's
happening yeah that happens to fit in
with human nature
that's probably true too yeah like i
don't believe that the
trump administration has the resources
to do that but still
i mean they would have to be so 4d chess
they would they would really have to be
they may like encourage it a little i
think they may just
pour a little gasoline on it maybe yeah
maybe
why not if they think that's their base
yeah they're like why not they're having
fun
when you go out to a trump rally you
want a little fun oh for sure
yeah yeah it's the things that he does
that are mistakes
yeah like these these interviews that he
does where he or he'll argue
about [ __ ] like he'll he'll argue about
how well they're doing
or what you know what's wrong or what he
got right or what his iq
is or how well he did at this uh
intelligence test like
anybody who's playing like 3d chess is
not going to do that no
no he's not playing any chess he's going
back instinct he's
he's riffing and we've said it before
i've said it on the show before it's
like
it's amazing to watch a guy get up no
material
and just crush i mean just he's really
going by instinct he's like
perf he's perfectly suited for this era
yeah because he's like he he's
hypnotizing
like if you start listening to him he
can't stop like i'll try to watch one
five minute clip of an interview i end
up watching the whole hour yeah because
he's like there's a hypnotic thing
that's going on where he just is up and
down and you're just
you can't not listen have you ever seen
scott adams talk about him
no scott adams is an interesting guy
he's a very intelligent guy he wrote the
dilbert comics you know yeah so he's
basically saying that trump is like a
master persuader and scott adams
understands hypnosis
and persuasion and interesting he's
talking about the way the guy does it
and how he does it that he's a master
persuader a lot of people disagree with
him but
what's interesting is he's not he
doesn't even vote scott adams doesn't
vote
and he's not really a trump supporter
although he does say a lot of things
that seem to
like i think he he leans
towards trump being more persuasive than
just going by his gut
because he sort of fills his he's got
this theory
yeah that aligns with his theory so he
goes a lot i see him leaning into it a
little bit where it's not like he's
totally objective about it
but he's lost millions of dollars
because millions
really like people oh [ __ ] yeah they've
turned on him he was saying on twitter
the other day that people uh slowed down
in front of his house started screaming
that he's a racist
jesus for nothing just because because
he said
that trump is persuasive right he said
that he thinks trump is essentially
pulling people strings and manipulating
people in a really interesting way
yeah and he is i mean like any president
does that
but trump does it extremely well he does
it a non-presidential way
right that's why it's weird yeah it's a
weird way of doing it he's a co
i love con artists and grifters and to
me trump is the highest level
biggest con ever most successful you
know without a question i mean like
you know he's the king of all of those
every guy sitting in an office
right now calling people up trying to
sell him [ __ ] over the phone
that's the trump's the kid trump's the
highest level that you can
i mean anybody i mean if you're using a
fake id
yeah to try to buy cigarettes up the
ladder
there's donald trump like all the way up
the lad and that
to me i think because everyone's like
he's evil or he's jesus
it's like i don't i don't look at things
that emotionally because i guess i'm
just not a total loser i think that's
really what it is
i think if your relief of nothing going
on
everything becomes about politics which
we don't
i'm never going to meet nancy pelo i
mean this is a television show right you
know i'm not saying that
real things don't happen that people
aren't affected but this day-to-day
like you're inundated with like he said
she's their policy schumer it's like
dude who cares my favorite pelosi
and schumer image of all time was them
with the african cloth yeah yeah
the enemies not realizing that the cloth
pattern they're wearing
was from a tribe that was notorious for
selling slaves
yeah yeah well notorious for being a
major part of the slave
yeah well so is the democratic party for
many years let's be honest that's what
people don't know
yeah that means when you go way back to
the democrats democrats were the
confederates yeah
whoops so and it's just we've been
looking at these people for too long
we've seen an image that's amazing i
love good but it's not as good as the
one when they're on their knees
i love the hands on the hips like oh and
the mask as well they've got everything
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's beautiful and
someone was saying that like well you
have to respect nancy pelosi someone
said that to me and i said
she wants 16 year olds to be able to
vote they look by the way
like invaders it just came into a
country slaughtered people and
took their clothing hopped off of a boat
yeah they look like people that just
colonized an area and took their cloth
yeah they're they're wearing like swamp
boots so they don't step into my blood
how old is she a million she's a
millionaire i mean
dude does anyone retire does anyone step
away no you you die at a trump rally
like herman cain
yeah what are you gonna do respect to
herman cain
respect no matter godfather yeah yeah
went out there no mask
he does what he wants but yeah he had
cancer and knitting he had cancer i
think oh did he yeah
well he died of covet yeah if you have
covet and you die of cancer you still
huge die to cover hit by a car you die
to coven i don't think they do it that
far but well
you'll see we'll see there's going to be
a documentary in a few years about this
i don't know
new york times are saying today they
think it's underreported they think that
the covet deaths are somewhere around
200 000.
yeah i mean listen i mean at a certain
point you just
you have to stop reading because
everything you read every hour
contradicts the last thing you've read
yeah and they're like it's airborne no
it's not yes it is no it's not i'm like
what do i do you can get it off surfaces
no you can't just kill me
like i don't know what's happening well
they don't know that's the problem
they're making it up on the go because
they're getting new data all the time
they're constantly getting new
information
new studies new things show but they
don't react to all the studies like
one of the big ones is the fact that it
dies in sunlight so right if that's the
case well you should let people do
all sorts of outdoor activities these
studies when you read about the studies
they're like we sampled a certain amount
of people
and this is what we found and it's like
that's not necessarily indicative
right of anything well it's it's
information it's better than nothing
yeah and it depends on who's reading the
study and what their bias is
and what they're trying to say um but
it's clear that they're trying to figure
this out i mean obviously it's only been
around for
six seven months and they say that the
people that are really reacting to it
in many cases a lot like for whatever
reason their immune system has not had
as many prior experiences with
coronaviruses so if your immune system
has gotten a lot of colds and you fought
them off
supposedly you're in a better position
to deal with this than somebody who has
not had that
germaphobes are [ __ ] yeah germaphobes
the fact that we were shaking hands and
on and off planes that might be good
that might have strengthened our immune
system well they were saying that about
people in prison
like one of the reasons why the people
in prison are doing so well with it like
when guys are in prison you would say oh
what a [ __ ]
terrible place for your immune system
but uh was it huberman
was it uh andrew huberman was talking to
us about this
i think it was he was saying might not
have been him too many guests
they were talking about immune systems
in that when you
think of your immune system you think
well if you're you're healthy and calm
and well slept and you know you're not
stressed out that's when your immune
system is at its best well that's not
really the case
and those people that are in jail
stuffed in next to all these people
breathing in everybody's bacteria and
all the viruses and [ __ ] that's in the
air no escape from each other no way to
social distance those people actually
have
pretty strong immune systems they're
doing good because their immune system
is
like in shape so the la homeless
population has got to be great
oh yeah they're probably they probably
have a natural immunity you know they
have
typhus i don't know you know that i have
no idea
they found typhus yeah yeah it's a
middle-aged disease
like it's come back because of like the
conditions that the you're in
the feces middle age medieval let me
[ __ ] that up every time i do that i'm
like this time i'm gonna get it right
nope i always say but they're doing good
with corona because they have strong
immune system so why don't we open the
comedy store up and just have the
homeless be the servers
like why can't we open up businesses in
la and just have the homeless
who've strengthened their immune systems
operate the businesses
let them shoot the voice
let homeless people go in and direct the
voice
i don't think they don't show up a lot
that's true they're
a good point liable they're unreliable
maybe you should have like three
homeless for each job
yeah like look someone's coming in
becky's ready becky's on standby
becca's over there shaking and
scratching
this is america's got talent there's 70
000 of them just in l.a
it's crazy they don't even know really
how many there are now because there's
70 000 of them before corona oh there's
going to be
there's going to be millions imagine if
there's a million homeless people
there's gonna be millions of homeless
people
it's gonna look very soon
like a and it's already starting to get
there like a movie
like a post-apocalyptic movie where you
drive down melrose
and everything's boarded up and you see
a lot like it's
gonna start looking really
bad here it could look really bad new
york is
a nightmare i've heard like new york the
crime is skyrocketing
and you know there's just
you know the the the relationship
between the police and the people is
very fraught and it's very hot i mean
it's like
so the police like [ __ ] it we don't want
to do anything and you're like you
understand a lot of they're just like
listen we're gonna sit back and then now
a lot of areas are just being policed by
criminal elements by gangs and
stuff like that because that's what
happens in a power vacuum you know if
you get rid of
the cops i'm not saying this shouldn't
be reformed they shouldn't have all
these new regulations but like
if you defund them or get rid of them
somebody steps into that vacuum
and it's going to be usually a gang the
mafia
crime syndicate whatever dude de blasio
not good
if you think your mayor is bad de blasio
is a nightmare he's like holding my beer
he's bad he's the worst he eats pizza
with a fork and what's great is that
he does he does yeah what's great is
that everyone hates them like the left
hates
them and that for different reasons and
then the right hates them
even the black lives matter people hate
them because they're all so pandering
what are you doing look at that oh
eating pizza with a fork he's disgusting
what kind of a [ __ ] human what is
this the mafia who's he sitting with
a bunch of old dead people who is this
looking at the moment how ridiculous
this is
is the teachers one guy with the sleeves
the guy with the sleeve tattoos he
better not eat that pizza with a fork i
will [ __ ] find him
yeah i mean de blasio he's a fake human
he's like a real human he's like a
goofball
yeah and he gets up with his wife they
did like a rally right after coronavirus
and like she gets up and she goes power
to the people and then she thought like
it was going to be like a 60s rally yeah
and then the crowd was just stared at
her like
what the [ __ ] we're gonna die ladies
yeah everyone's coffin
yeah they thought it was gonna be like
they were gonna start beating
tambourines like power to the people
like
her and de blasio think they're like
living some historic
moment and though they are that's just
not what they just not what they think
they're in the wrong movie yeah it's uh
it's rough man yeah
cities are in trouble yeah well he he
literally said
you can only protest if it's a black
lives matter protest
yeah let's listen as much as i support
the movement that is
not freedom of speech you can't do that
no that's anti-first amendment yeah but
this is a big part of who we are you
can't
say no you can only do one kind of
protest
everybody's got a protest or nobody's
got to protest right everyone's got to
be allowed
you gotta allow the anti-mass people
with candace owens singing songs with
sean hannity
and you need to let the black lives
matter people do it everybody's got to
be able to protest yeah i mean i'm out
in the da i rented a house in the desert
and it's 119 degrees every day so peop
not only can people not protest
you can't leave your house without dying
like if you leave your house you get
skin cancer sauna life
yeah and they tried to do a protest it
lasted like sort of got less than three
blocks
they were like back like they were
banging a thing they were like no
justice
they were like no no pete like they had
no idea and then
they were sitting down you saw them like
sitting down eating ice
i am one hundred percent for police
reform hundred percent 100
i 100 believe there's too much police
brutality too much i am also
100 in in the belief that there's a lot
of people that are doing this
and following this movement because like
we were talking about before with actors
it is the trendy thing to do social and
then also
what you're seeing in like portland and
seattle you're seeing crazy white people
trying to light government buildings
yeah well they think if they if they
bash the windows of amazon this is the
beginning of the revolution
how is it at all connected to police
it's crazy
it is not connected at all it's just
anarchy it's just chaos
when you unleash that like in the
beginning of this like listen you burn
down a target it was fine i even laughed
i said it was a [ __ ]
it's in minneapolis like did this happen
in minneapolis so what a target gets it
in minneapolis the guy gets charged the
next day it's fine
but when you unleash total chaos you
know more about violence than anybody
you can't control it no you can't direct
it to the to the targets that you think
are
right it's also intoxicating and fun
right all those people that are involved
in it wearing masks showing up every day
having a good time they're giving their
it gives their life meaning
right it does they're trying to beat the
man right they're trying to break down
the [ __ ] fence they put around the
federal building and they're trying to
light that [ __ ] on fire using
bibles right they're lighting bibles on
fire jesus i mean it's all chaos
it's just insane how about the mayor of
seattle's like maybe this is our summer
of
love yeah there i've never been there i
don't want to ever go
like i have not the pacific northwest i
hate it i know you do i don't give a
[ __ ] of those people
i don't care about those trees and the
trails and they all look like vampires
they're pale
and gaunt freaks they're so weird amway
that scam started up there like
multi-level marketing startup there yeah
they're all looking for something to
believe in and that's that
those are problem areas well that's
where brett weinstein was teaching at
evergreen
and they and that's where they came like
patrolling the campus with bats
looking for him he's like he's a as
literally as progressive as a human can
get right
and he's also a nerd yeah super nice guy
yeah and they you know they were coming
for him it's it's
i've never liked there's something about
the pacific northwest i've just never
i never connected with it i thought
about living there once yeah but i mean
that's your you love that stuff
i don't give a [ __ ] it happens all the
time i i know but that's why these
people are out throwing bibles at the
federal building
is because it's raining all the time
well i don't know what makes that place
so progressive and so left-wing but
the thing is is that like you saw hints
of this many years ago
where antifa would stop traffic yeah
like doing these things and stuff and
when people would they would get people
to say black lives matter it's like
what's the point is before that
they weren't they weren't connected with
black lives matter before
the coronavirus thing before george
floyd the antifa people
it was all about right-wing people it
was all about combating
right-wing folks right like the proud
boy they would have those skirmishes
exactly right well that's where the
proud boys came from they came from
speakers exactly they wanted someone to
fight back against antifa when he was
shutting down
correct people who are speaking at
colleges who are right-wing people like
milo
or anybody whatever yeah those kind of
people so that's where it all came from
in the first place but
when you would go to seattle they were
letting these [ __ ] people
direct traffic or was it portland it
might have been portland
they were letting these [ __ ] people
direct they were telling people you
can't go down this road
yeah and so this old man was like i'm
going and they started chasing him and
they kicked his ass they're beating on
his [ __ ] car
yeah i don't know why people on twitter
defend that
and i don't know why a lot of
celebrities defend it and i don't
understand why
a lot of mainstream democrats don't just
call that out for what it is i've never
once seen
a mainstream republican ever i mean
defend like the proud boys or or or that
was certainly not their hill to die on
like right if a mainstream republican
defended them it was very like it was a
huge news story
usually i don't know why i think the big
problem is
it's like things are happening you see
them with your own eyes and then people
tell you
that they're not happening right they're
like no that protest is peaceful you're
like
i saw them light a guy on fire and use
him as a battering ram to get into
macy's
they're like well you know he gave them
a look there's always a qualifier
it was this weird qualifier yeah they're
like well here's what happened you're
like they were beating a child they're
like
let me explain what happened yeah they
were gathered together
they had burning bibles bows and arrows
bike locks and chains
that child crossed the street that child
said my dad's a cop
you see the child starting you're like
no
there's always a weird like but they
first they're the thugs of the left wing
they're they're doing the dirty work
that the left wing wants to get
they're like theater kids they're like
people that failed at stand-up comedy in
theater and
they moved back to portland from la and
now they're like let's burn it all down
i didn't get a comedy central half hour
you've never seen them really what it is
you ever see the ones that are
practicing self-defense no they train
they actually train
they're like they were these antifa
people were meeting in the park and they
were getting ready for skirmishes with
the right-wing people
this is all pre-coveted right when this
was funny right you know right right
this was funny when it stopped being
funny was uh how do you pronounce his
last name
go andy no andy yeah yeah yeah when andy
no got beat up and then they
shaked him and people were mocking and
i'm like hey why do you think it's okay
to beat this guy up like
why do you think it's okay to steal this
guy's camera like yeah what is that no
one is saying this
yeah then i started to say like okay
this is this is gonna be a real problem
and then the economy got shut down and
you can and you're like oh this will
only make
this bigger yeah and bigger yeah this
will only fuel the fire
but again it's like these people who'd
go there whether they're trying to light
the federal building on fire
or direct traffic they have a purpose
now
they have a thing and they have a cause
right like when they took over that
six sec six block section of portland or
seattle rather yeah
yeah or what was it that ch chow what
what
it was jazz or chop chop chop chop
but it started as jazz but young
countries often
have you know they changed leadership
hiccups and as they developed
i was gonna have that guy on my show the
guy razz yeah i was too then i got
caught with a gun
i know he was handing a a ak to someone
or whatever i still would have had him
but we couldn't get a zoom link working
i was going to have him here in person
really yeah interesting that would have
been fun
maybe yeah i was like listen man i
support you
do you know doing your thing but you
can't bring it out of the gun it's like
and i didn't even then they shoot dude
they shot two people there
well i don't know he didn't shoot well
he didn't somebody definitely did
the other thing they were doing that was
crazy was they basically became a really
shittily run country
they put up borders almost immediately
immediately
barriers they weren't borders when
people were doing things they didn't
want them to do they were the worst case
of police brutality they just beat the
[ __ ] they just beat people up so if you
were trying to film them
doing something they didn't want you to
film they just kick your ass well this
is just like if you believe in something
really fervently not not like it's
always the ends justify the means like
however you get there it doesn't matter
right like anything's justified in the
pursuit of this utopia that you think
you're going to erect
in downtown seattle well it's also
you're doing for seven blocks
what you think shouldn't have been done
to america you're occupying land
right you're taking over existing
structures you're kicking out the
indigenous people of seattle
yeah i think i you know the shitty thing
is like electoral politics isn't perfect
but that's what you have to do like look
at cortez
she got elected you know like the people
that believe the things you believe
can get elected they have to work within
the system
because all the violence that chaos will
do will give the government a reason to
even clamp down more
now they got people and throwing people
in advance in portland the dhs because
again you're not going to overthrow the
government right you're not gonna
overthrow the military it's not the way
it's gonna work right they can catch you
breaking
public property it's just gonna be an
excuse for them to clamp down
more and it's gonna where we're gonna be
in more of a police state than we were
yeah the idea that when they did that
that somehow another incited the
violence to get worse like that is i
don't know if that's true
no it was it was chaos every night for
50 days
i'm not for the unmarked vans i think
that's a bad i think all of those things
end up being because look at what
happened after 9 11 they said we're
going to do this this and this and then
all of a sudden
nobody got any rights back by the way
your emails are still being read you
have no privacy
all of that's still there so if we just
establish a precedent of like yep some
people need to get thrown in a van
and we'll explain we'll explain uh why
that is
yeah that becomes a major problem going
forward did you see when they got thrown
into vans how excited everybody else was
what's your name what's your name we'll
get you out friends right it's like
you guys are all on luke skywalker this
is what happened
the resistance when you shut a country
down for three months this is the only
fun left
yeah nothing's open anymore the only fun
fun thing to do is to overthrow the
government get thrown in the van
yeah this is summer vacation to people
yeah this is a you know they used to
have those dumb escape rooms that people
used to do
escape rooms you shut the [ __ ] up
they're stupid i love them but this is a
real one
this is a fun real one now it is a fun
how fun is that how do you like the
federal building
now it's now it's a real one yeah yeah
it's uh it's interesting man and i
wonder how these people are going to
transition into regular grown-up life
afterwards well i think that's [ __ ] joe
i think regular grown-up life to ship
itself on both sides like
the people that were in charlottesville
marching around like we're gonna have a
white country
we're gonna i mean these people they
will not replace us yeah they will yeah
it's like those people are as well
you'll never please
the far left and the far right right
like you'll never like the people that
are really on the fringes
you're never going to make them happy
like kamala harris by the way
is a fine vp choice yes we're all going
to get put in jail
yes she's going to put you in jail but
guess what who is he going to pick
elizabeth warren who lied about being a
native american
like kamal is good because the people in
the middle
don't care that she's a cop no one gives
a [ __ ]
no one cares you might care that she
locked up people but the republican
conventions could be very tough
to really get people mad at kamala
harris they're gonna be like
[ __ ] come all everyone's gonna go yeah
they're gonna go she's a cop and she
locked up minorities he'll probably just
go
ah
is this a real problem like i just think
what do you think you think she's the
worst i don't think she's the worst
but uh i think it's it's very int well
somebody wrote on twitter that the left
is
very much against sexism and racism
yet they elected someone or they chose
someone to be a bp based entirely on
their sex and their race
right but we knew that was going to
happen we knew that was this is why all
these people on twitter and guys that i
really like like i really love kyle
kalinski and those people
but it's like they were like so mad
about it i'm like guys didn't you see it
was gonna happen
didn't you didn't you like ever it's the
most predictable choice in history
i was thinking if they went nuclear
michelle obama that would have been wild
right right right right right
one they would have won they would have
won and cuomo from new york like
meatball the governor of new york
meatball and michelle obama
win did you see the latest cuomo thing
no what's he doing now
kyle kalinski sent me this i mean he's
out of control over there
him and his bro his brother pretended to
have coronavirus by the way
they pretended well his brother chris
cuomo said he beat coronavirus by doing
chest exercises what swear to god
there's a youtube video where chris
cuomo is going
you know this virus gets in your body
and wants to stay there but you know
what you just start stretching your
chest
doing this you get rid of it that's
literally i mean he's never forget liar
liar
is that true yes he's alive you're gonna
stretch your chest yes if you can find
it jamie it's real
and he said he cured himself he cured
himself by doing chest exercises
and stretching his lungs out well the
worst part was when he pretended to come
out of the basement for the first time
when he had already been in a in a
[ __ ] fight with some guys no these
people
on the bike they're pathological liars
both of them i don't think that's what
the case is
okay this is my take from a person who's
worked in show business for a long time
i think he had a producer that had at
cnn and they had this shot scheduled
you're going to we're going to film you
coming out of the basement it's going to
be amazing you're going to race your
family for the first time
in two weeks okay did the producer make
it pretend to have
a virus protecting his wall street
donors from democratic tax bills
um so this is uh but the tweet i sent
you jamie
but i didn't send you the tweet here it
is new disclosure records show andrew
cuomo's
largest headphone hedge fund donor just
funneled huge money
to the governor precisely the moment
cuomo has been blocking
democratic legislators bills to
reinstate new york's financial
transactions tax
that's crazy that is crazy
it's nuts if that's the tr if that's the
case
if like he knew that tax was coming
and he blocked it just so that he could
get paid
i don't know enough about financing i
don't know houses
tell me i was a subprime mortgage guy i
mean i know these things
i mean what i mean you're my guy i go to
yeah well good
i mean i i i i it's very possible that
he did block it so he could get paid i
mean these people give themselves raises
constantly no matter what circumstances
are
no matter what shortfall the city
government's in these people constantly
give themselves raises yeah and cuomo's
got to play an interesting game because
wall street money is how new york is
even alive if enough wall street people
leave you they're [ __ ] well they're
[ __ ] right now they're [ __ ] right
now
fifty percent of the taxes in new york
are paid by the rich right and they're
leaving like one percent of the people
pay fifty percent of that yeah a lot of
them went to the hamptons a lot of them
got out of the city and a lot of them
were leaving the city
forever right so you you know you could
[ __ ] on the rich blah blah i think a lot
of them should
you know a lot of them get get out of
paying taxes by routing their money
offshore and they do a lot of things
they shouldn't do
but that tax base is essential
for that city 100 100 100 and this is
where and also
foreign criminals as sad as it is
third world dictators chinese amusement
park tycoons russian oligarchs
and assorted murderers you need their
money
yeah otherwise how you gonna sell stock
that's the reality like they have to
come in and launder their money
through new york real estate they got to
come in and buy 10 apartments they don't
use
and then their daughter goes to nyu i i
mean otherwise that whole city is going
to fall apart it's not right or wrong
good or bad
it's like it's just what's gonna happen
it's just what it is did you see cuomo
trying to bring the rich people back
it's like come on over i'll cook yeah
i'll cook he they're go he's a goon how
many people are you cooking for bro he's
an idiot this is that folksy horse [ __ ]
that they do like i'll make a meatball
for you it's like i'll cook for you yeah
how about
not letting the city get destroyed how
about not sending sick
old people to the nursing home where
they can infect everybody else well that
i was for
i think a good i think a good brush fire
through the nursing homes is good
to be honest with you oh god i mean my
mother's in a nursing home her
her roommate had covered for a month
my mother never got it every day they
would go in and they were like well you
my mother's an annoying woman loud
looks like me every day they walked in
they're like will you die
she's like i feel great so we're all
hoping second wave
but um it's like
it's you know she won't die the woman's
300 pounds she won't die
she won't die what is she eating
everything
probably her roommate who dyed a coconut
she's probably eating her
but the woman won't die she's indeed
fatigable like they
they can't great yeah i i whip it out
here i don't know say it right i don't
think i said i couldn't say medieval
yeah here he is here it is this is how
he beat corona
i don't think that i think he's just
talking about the tightness no no no no
no
he is stop defending him
i have to defend all this this is insane
because i have too much of that in me
this is
this is the vaccine for coronavirus by
the way going like this stretching he's
stretching
stretching i like how the stairs are
behind him yeah it's all
horseshit he looks fine he's probably
upset yeah it's probably sad
he's not sick he's like he goes you know
he goes this fires gets in he wants to
kill you but he goes you know what i do
he goes i just stretch the lungs stretch
the lungs then and it's like okay so we
shut down the economy
for three months for a virus where you
can just stretch your lungs you can
stretch the lungs and then that's it
something's off well this virus is
[ __ ] up because yeah if you talk to
some people it's nothing
and i know people that have gotten it
they're [ __ ] and they're not and other
people that have gotten it and they're
[ __ ] still
right like i think michael yeoh is still
having a problem with fatigue my man
my ex managers uh his wife got it she
still can't smell
whoa how long ago three months she still
she can smell a few things
jesus i know is she healthy yeah she's a
thin
you know middle-aged woman yeah it's
weird and they are also saying that
some large number of people that get it
they still they have uh heart damage
so after it's over they show like that
baseball player there's a professional
baseball player that has to sit out the
rest of the season
he got checked out i mean i think he's
29 years old or something like that
and they found out that he has uh some
inflammation in his heart
nobody knows why any of this is
happening well i take it back to brett
weinstein again because
yeah brett who's a biologist was saying
that this disease has
all the markers of a disease that's been
manipulated for research
right that's why it does it's so
infectious now manipulated for research
like manipulated so that they can
research it or manipulate it as like how
can we make something dangerous that
might be a weapon
no they manipulate it so that they can
do research on it so they can find out
what kind of cures they can create for
coronavirus
interesting the lab that they did uh
research at was in wuhan and it's a
level four lab by a research facility
and they had been cited in 2018 for
safety violations they're getting real
sloppy over there because when you're
working under communism you don't have a
lot of incentives
right right a lot of money
is true it's very possible that it this
is a genetically
modified virus and that and maybe that's
why it has all of these different
effects on people
exactly exactly and it's probably
morphing like they say the one in india
is so different that if we come up with
a vaccine for
the american version it's not going to
work on the indian version
is this just the rest of the for the
history now is just
viruses and pandemics and like i mean
this seems to be
because all the conditions for this you
know
are are are are you know gonna still be
there
like they're still gonna be these wet
markets they'll still be
uh you know a lot of unsafe handling of
of of of
produce and and not only produce but
like you know different types of animals
and
so this may not be the end of this maybe
the beginning of an
era of just different types of pandemics
and viruses well they've been warning us
about this for a while yeah bill gates
had that ted speech
yeah in 2015 he said it's coming yeah
and you know now he's the devil now
everybody's like bill gates
i just think people get weirdly
uncomfortable when it's like
billionaires want to do like bill gates
was considering once shooting a missile
of dust at the sun
to help climate change this is a fact
what
yes so he was considering this and then
yeah where'd you read this this is what
kind of dust
uh how big the sun is yeah but bill
gates was considering
shooting a missile full of dust at the
center so it's like now obviously people
said to him hey
not a good idea and he relented but when
you have these batman
villain billionaires not that they're
evil but that they have a lot of money
they can do whatever they want
people get uncomfortable with just one
guy
saying this is the way it is and this is
what you need people just feel
uncomfortable you find that
is that real that's real joe could
dimming the sun save the earth bill
gates wants to spray millions and tons
of dust into the stratosphere okay
that's different
to stop global warming but critics fear
it could triple calamity
yeah that's not at the sun but what that
is the suspending particles in the
atmosphere they're going to act as like
understood but the reality is people get
a little
they get a little uncomfortable when a
billionaire from a lair
is decided to start shooting dust into
the atmosphere
and you know where is where is the is
there any democratic
process here where anybody will ever
have any say in anything ever again
or are we just going to listen to bezos
and him do it in there they could do
whatever they want well it's hard to say
because when you're that rich we listen
anyway
because we figured bezos has got 200
billion
or something he's must know something
that we don't know we assume
sure but i mean smarter than who knows
what you know
also they have a lot of money i don't
even think they want more money i think
a lot of them just
they want more well some of them do but
they also have they just have designs in
the way they want the world to look
they have an ideology i trust bezos more
than i trust bill
because bezos doesn't wear a uniform
bill gates wears that
mr rogers uniform yeah i don't trust it
i don't
i trust warren buffett because i feel
like he's in omaha just eating
eggs he lives in the same [ __ ] house
that he bought like that's a scam no
he does that he does that so guys like
us would be like what a down to earth
guy like but he's a billion dollars
lives in a 400 000
house something's wrong that makes me
more suspicious than i would be if he
had a man he should have a big match
bill gates well that's not even his
regular outfit the regular that's the
regular outfit yeah
he's a little sweater with the shirt
what are you doing it's 100 degrees bill
what do you wear then you know do you
wear the same sweater with the shirt
look he's got that [ __ ] he loves it
but why is that that's the tech outfit
man that's the silicon valley they're
gonna
people just get very nervous with
silicon valley billionaires
well it's an incredible amount of money
and it's an incredible amount of
influence people are
really worried about mark zuckerberg
yeah these guys are the new rockefeller
carnegie
and he's [ __ ] really young he's
really young by the way speaks perfect
mandarin
well he's got a girl who's he's twice
right yeah he's married jesus christ
i don't know what he's doing i'm not
invited to his home you're not
i'll get you in i'd love to all you have
to do is get your facebook page over 700
000
i'd love to go i'd get banned from
facebook within an hour of being there
be taken away i just i just go up to him
and go can you get rid of my aunt
kathleen please
it's a crazy video of him in china and
uh he's on a television show and he
starts speaking
in mandarin and they go crazy they can't
believe he can do it they're clapping
and cheering
interesting it takes very little to
impress them huh well they're just it's
just a white guy he's doing it
he's the guy from facebook speaking
perfect mandarin wow but he's ready
that's comforting by the way he's going
to bring them all the head of
the head of facebook is yucking it up
with you know maybe our biggest enemy
yeah that's nice
he's going to be super excited about new
world order give me some volume on this
[Music]
the translation is america will be a
prison we
will send your government to rule hour
this is what happens when you're like a
genius and you don't get laid in college
and you just say you know what i'm just
going to take over the world this is
like pinky in the brain but the real
thing well he's also
a guy who is friends with the people who
put together
facebook yeah that's a great movie
social networking i didn't see the movie
but i really like
articles real story the actual real
story is kind of [ __ ] up
yeah he kind of well there were those
winklevoss twins and they had this
harvard
dating app or something and then
zuckerberg came in i think zuckerberg
had more of a vision of what he wanted
it to be but it was certainly sketch
it's a little sketchy the way that
happened yeah but the fact that they're
trying to do money now they're trying to
do facebook bitcoin like uh
i don't know how it's still relevant
like when you go on facebook now it's
just still crazy people screaming
yeah and and and they've still kept them
all on there they've kept them on there
like zuckerberg's figured out a way to
keep the boomers on facebook
yeah just sharing recipes and and
complaining about
you know yeah they're just talking about
cuda my aunt's like save the children
and here's a recipe for banana bread
my aunt's like there's tunneled under
central park and i'm making a banana
cream pie later
so if you want the recipe i mean
literally it's recipes and q drops
that's my aunt's face
i mean it's her head is melted i've
talked to multiple people that really
truly believe
in the q and on stuff well some of it
some of it listen some of it you gotta
give him the benefit of the doubt it's
like
i don't even blame the q and on people
as much because like
if you were ignorant of everything and
you never thought anything was
conspiratorial and then epstein and all
this stuff happen your mind would melt
oh yeah and that's what happened they
just i've been listening and following
weird [ __ ]
i mean i remember when 911 was a big
thing now nobody even care like you
bring that up people roll their eyes
remember that things change that was a
huge thing and it was like we're going
to get the answers and then people just
stop caring
and then you move on to this and then in
five years q and on people be like
they'll stop
caring and then it'll be another thing
and eventually you just have to like
kind of check
out because it gets boring well you kind
of wonder
disinformation campaigns have existed
forever where they take legitimate
information and then they
lump it in with nuts yes crazy [ __ ]
crazy people and crazy [ __ ]
and then they put it out there because
it taints all the legitimate information
as well 100 percent you know there's a
great book uh behold the pale horse you
ever read yeah william cooper or
something yeah yeah yeah
you read some of it and you go oh this
makes sense and then you go what what a
[ __ ] alien base on the moon like
what's going on yeah
yeah and then some of it just goes left
it gets really crazy yeah it's
patrice o'neal like a great point where
he's like the people will be
they'll then they'll say two things that
make a lot of sense and then they'll put
marbles up their ass
that's the way he said it but it was
true and he said it on o a it was like
but it's hard but eventually just for
your own mental health you got to check
out yeah you got to just go you know
what there's more to life
than politics and there's just more to
life than hunting
this conspiracy forever because it's not
none of what you think is going to
happen is going to happen
i think that's part of what you you just
nailed it though there's more to life
but there's not for some people yeah
some people if they put on a [ __ ]
maga hat
and they you know they have [ __ ] uh
liberals with a line through it
and they go out there and they [ __ ]
yeah that's it and they get to the rally
i was i was out there in the desert they
had all these women and they're in you
know mercedes like
beautiful day not as hot as it usually
is women in like top-down mercedes you'd
think like on a day like that you just
go out take a drive
put an album on go take a drive yeah up
the mountains
beautiful instead they had these pink
women for trump flags
and they all met on a corner and they're
all waving their flags and it's like
golf people it's like like middle
you know upper middle class golf people
and this is their sports it was like
high school spirit night
i wish her well yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that's what it is and and it's just
like the again i
thank god i found comedy thank god i
have something i like to do yeah
because i maybe i'd be somewhere with a
flag waving a flag running around
that's what it is right right like i
need things to do nobody has hobbies
not only does nobody have hobbies where
right now no one has a job that's a
problem
so there's like no money coming in
you're desperate you're scared
yeah you're blaming other people
everybody else you don't know who the
[ __ ] is to blame
you have no idea and then there's a
disease that might kill you
yeah so that you you're anxious yeah
you're depressed yeah
your social circle has been cut
dramatically dramatically and
now the only thing you could do is kind
of go online for 19 hours a day and get
radicalized
in whatever direction that's the thing
that bothers me too
about like whenever people talk about uh
whether it's conspiracy theorists or
whatever
the one thing that drives me nuts is
that people say we have to stop these
conspiracy like
when all these covid conspiracies were
going around that well that's a
different one right because
i guess some of them could be actually
responsible for people
making poor choices none of those people
were going to make good choices before
that
that's my point yeah it's like if
there's people out there that are
pushing
ridiculous conspiracy theories like who
are you worried about are you worried
about it getting to you right no
you're not right you're not worried
about you believing it right so you
think you're smarter than everybody else
yeah well i think it's just people get
deeply uncomfortable
with the idea that they're losing
control of the public sphere
the public space right for so long you
had these
these mainstream media outlets they had
real direct control
i mean everything you saw everything you
watched everything you read it was
under the control of a relatively small
amount of people
and this was how it was forever right i
mean this was not like
an aberration this was literally how it
was forever every single thing you read
or saw
was curated by a small group of people
and now it's the wild west yeah
and a lot of people don't and you're
gonna get bad information you're gonna
get good information you're gonna have
to figure out which is which
and the country is not good at doing
that people are not good at doing that
and so people get worried and they're
like wait a minute but you can't put the
genie back in the bottle
well the problem is they can right and
they will
pandemic and all these different things
yeah and the video of the bunch of
doctors talking about hydroxychloroquine
and z-packs and and that woman who's a
witch doctor i liked her
i like that witch doctor and i want to
hear more about i find her
opinions on on on demons [ __ ] you
more interesting than kova she needs a
podcast she needs a pi i don't care
about hydroxychloroquine i want to know
who are these demons who [ __ ] you in
your sleep we should have her on you and
me
please if you get her me
you and her would be phenomenal we could
fly her and she wouldn't even wear a
mask
she would not wear a mask she'd fight a
cop at lax
where does she would be great i have no
idea where where does that look where
does that woman live
she practices medicine in this trip mall
have you seen it no it's literally like
right next to it
a lot of doctors are [ __ ] like a lot
of doctors dude a large percentage
especially in l.a well doctors are
humans
humans go to school they learn to be a
doctor there's a lot of crazy humans you
know whitney cummings said everyone she
goes my doctor friend said it's a
practice which means we're still
practicing it's like well that's not
comforting that's not what practice
means that's not at all what practice
means
you freak but there is
la there's so many you're doing and i'm
like do you even have a degree did you
go to medical school
that kind of logic is like when people
say program when to talk about tv
programs
they're programming you bro right
they're letting you know it's that
stupid like linguistic garbage
what announcements yeah are you are you
is there any part of you that's gonna
miss los angeles
oh yeah yeah i'm going to miss it sure
i'm just going to miss the store
i'm but i'm missing the los angeles that
i don't think exists right now
right when you go down melrose and you
see everything boarded up and you see
[ __ ] homeless encampments everywhere
like i took the wife to venice yeah and
i've talked about this before
unfortunately
sorry if you heard it before but driving
by i parked at a red light you know
stopped at a red light rather and
there's this [ __ ] house to my left
it's probably worth five million dollars
and right across the street there's ten
tents right so imagine
you your [ __ ] kid is in your front
lawn you you made it you got a beautiful
house in venice
well five minutes from the beach i love
it you've got ten
junkies camped out in front of your
[ __ ] house and needles in the street
like this is crazy and there's [ __ ]
tents everywhere yeah
i was in brentwood this morning it's
chaos yeah
dude you get off the 405. it's just
garbage stacked up
seven feet high intense [ __ ] hibachi
grills out there
yeah that's why yeah i mean that's why i
got this house in the desert because i'm
like i just want to get out and you know
as soon as you get out there
something happens where it gets really
calm really hot
and there's none of that that's why i'm
moving to texas yeah yeah same thing
texas is like that yeah
texas is like the regular world but you
wear a mask
yeah and a lot of people from texas
you're all upset that i'm
talking about it so much and people are
moving out there but i'm sorry
sorry you're awesome sorry you got an
awesome spot yeah it just seems like
the first of all high population centers
it's just this is not a time for high
population centers this is letting
everybody know
that the whole idea of like living in
manhattan this is going to be great
everything's there
right right yeah it was it was great
here she is
houston texas
firepower ministries i love that whoa
weapon of war what fire power where's
that weapon of war give me the full
image hold on a second you've got hold
on back back back back
i can't yeah make it there fire power
ministries
what is that god's battle axe and weapon
of war see that i would have went right
to the website but it was not working
fire power ministries
look at what it says there god's battle
axe and weapon of war
i love it i need that tattooed yeah i
think i'm gonna get that on my right leg
power ministries i love that ammunition
ministries
and weapon of war 47 ministries i'm
going to put that on my heel
where is she the christian resource
center it's right there that sounds good
fire power ministries
fire power ministries prayer deliverance
counseling bookstore print shop
gifts i will send a limo to get you
gifts and more
bring you to austin we do a podcast
we're going to have a good time
it sounds fun it looks legit yeah look
at
this
the whole witchcraft section hey well if
you don't get a book on richcraft how
are you going to learn you got to go to
a witch and they might lie to you
i'm all for her protecting us from
witches well
god's battle axe and weapon of war like
imagine right now on your twitter
man this is her everybody out there
please listen to me i i've never asked
for anything for you people
i want everybody to update your twitter
bio to god's battle axe and weapon of
war i want everyone to do yeah i may do
that
it's important to show solidarity with
that woman and her
god's battle axe and weapon fire power
firepower ministries
yes god's battle axe and weapon of war
profile
edit profile here we go everybody's
coming out of the woodwork
now like you have a lot of different you
know if you have if you had anything to
do with medicine at all
you could come out now and just you
could you could build a brand
yeah she's building a brand the bible
verse apparently oh really yeah yeah
oh really yeah you want my war club yeah
maybe i should leave it alone then yeah
[Laughter]
she's building a brand yeah i understand
what they're doing yeah
hey no you got to build a brand it's
just what it is not everybody could be
alyssa milana some
unless milana some people have to be
god's weapon of war
yeah battle axe battle axe and weapon of
war what a crazy bible quote
there's some bible quotes that make you
go well they don't the people like her
they don't want the light touch
bible quote no they don't want to like
give the old man soup or whatever you
know some version of that they want like
the fires will reign through your eye
like that type of intense
yes yes yeah yeah the apocalypse they're
into that
so many people just really love that
vivid imagery from like book of
revelation yes
they want that yes that's the only part
of the bible a lot of them care about
yeah they just want the end they think
it's coming what's going on here give me
something
give me some of this what is she saying
you know one of us that yes we gave our
life to christ but we've been living in
sin
right oh no we did no we believe that
god exists but we've never surrendered
our all to him
it's unreasonable that's not reasonable
but because of the
case don't be afraid to give your all at
christ i'd feel comfortable if she
walked into a
hospital waiting room and started
treating me i'd feel very comfortable
and then she brought that guy out
and she goes now meet my uh nurse this
is my head nurse
you know what is interesting though is
this
the politicalization is that a word oh
this
[Music]
that's de blasio's wife trying to get
trying to get a response from people
inside
to the people nothing yeah yeah
yeah you gotta wonder
it's a real nightmare out there it's
weird yeah it's really weird if we can
stay alive it's awesome though as long
as nobody love dies in this
it's a good deal yeah i think if we come
out on the other end which i think will
be next spring i think we could go
through the fall and winter it's going
to be weird the election's weird like
have you ever
have you ever looked forward to three
months less no then these three months
of just intense i have intense anxiety
about the election
right like i'm where i'm like yeah this
could be bad
could go could go interestingly it could
be a real mess in this country
i think it'll be a mess no matter who
gets in i'd be less of a massive biden
i think if biden wins it'll be less of a
mess and i think people will shut i'm
hoping people will shut
up like can people just shut up
they're not gonna shut up yeah they're
not gonna shut up because first of all
the trump people if biden wins they're
gonna be furious
right and uh trump has said that like
that this mail-in vote thing is gonna be
right for fraud he's not maybe he's not
wrong about that either
i don't know enough about it but i don't
know why we can't have a regular
election with masks
uh well i don't know why we can't
entertain this scene as how you and i
don't know what the [ __ ] we're talking
about let's just go all in
and say uh i believe it could be a fraud
wait the mail in yeah i think it could
be two
i think they should vote online how come
you could do banking
because then russian trolls and chinese
trolls and all the trolls and bots
meanwhile you bank online no problem
what what's more important you than your
money nothing nothing it's a good point
meanwhile they figured out how to do
that let's just have a regular election
six feet distancing mask
spray everything down in between i mean
what are we doing the phone
opens up with your face right yeah mine
does at least or your fingerprint why
can't you use that well i just
i agree with you but i don't know why we
can't have a traditional regular
election with masks and distancing
we certainly can i think we can i think
it's stupid not to
especially in an election that's going
to be this contentious anyway we should
probably just have a regular election
with masks and distancing
i wonder what it's going to be like at
the polls and then like if really
elderly people
yes you should go to nursing homes
they're really elderly people and let
them
let them touch a computer screen like
let my mother go in there and let my
mother touch it because she loves trump
she asked me the other day
she goes can you get me a maga hat i'm
like yeah yeah
she's schizophrenic but she loves her
she's kind of his base
she does she does she goes
yeah she goes um uh yeah she goes i love
trump she goes he's just trying to do
the right thing for the country
you know i'm gonna take a picture of you
in full stride she goes your aunt donna
doesn't understand that donald trump's
trying
to save us from the people that want to
hurt us i was like yeah
i was like that's aunt donna always
trying to let the people in to hurt us
[ __ ] aunt donna everybody has one
yeah so i mean that's my uh here's a
question yeah
who's gonna name the kid karen after all
this oh god that name's out it's all
right but you know timmy
my name that happened to you too every
[ __ ]
that was being described in the 80s was
like little timmy
everyone everyone dude and that name is
decreased and popular which is fine i
don't want it i don't want a name that
everyone has
but everybody that was the [ __ ] name
forever was like timmy what about adolf
by the way not a good guy great name
it's not a bad name it's a great name
yeah it's a strong name wilhelm clip
this and send this around
it's a strong name
[Laughter]
wilhelm you can't use it anymore you
can't use uh
you can't use adolf anymore yeah but how
many kids a year let's ask
let's do it a poll right how many kids a
year are named adolf
probably nobody nobody right
i want to know i want to know how many
you want to talk about a social justice
warrior the guy who's named adolf's got
to go hard
left what uh well actually well hold on
what does it say
i thought this was like a us article
that was it say worldwide an article
um europe's all in there's official
records on it apparently so um
official records show that only 13
children were named adolf between 2006
and 2013.
follow them netflix stocks made a small
comeback since then 46 children have
been named adolph since then oh yeah the
way germany's going there's going to be
a lot of it off
yeah cause they got some issues and how
easy is that how how low that number is
follow those 13 kids that's a great
netflix documentary like you just call
it 13 adolfs
and you follow them and see like how
they deal with how they deal with having
the name of a you know a genocidal
monster really
but maybe you could be jengas you could
name your kid
jengas nobody is it genghis or jenga
genghis genghis khan
i like genghis genghis is fine too i've
said genghis but i think you're really
supposed to say jengas
oh katrina caitlin hey wait a minute
hold on no more caitlyn's
monica monica's are out isis there's a
few eyes
dude have you ever gone somewhere and
you see somewhat of middle eastern
descent and their name is isis
it's like a beautiful name isis alan's
rough
ellen is like an old but it's a rough
one now it's a rough one now because she
was running abu ghraib in the back of
her show
that's a rough one she's out there
dancing with kristen ballen in the back
there's people
that are getting up on the rack like
this it's so weird when you see
like a lot of people saying that someone
who seems so nice
is not nice at all she doesn't seem nice
but that's that people have a very poor
judge of character
she doesn't seem nice it seems forced
people that are like that all the time
it doesn't seem nice it's very
forced and whatever you're allowed to be
a [ __ ] right you're allowed to be a
[ __ ] you're allowed to be nasty to
people you're accomplished you're a
comedian you did the whole thing
what you're not allowed to do um is
have a guantanamo bay situation in the
backstage of your show where
everybody's walking around afraid for
their life and it's like abu ghraib
where they're hooked up to wires and
they
yeah she's got dogs and hoods if an
intern is late they have a hood on
i don't support that that's just me yeah
yeah i'm with you yeah i mean you know i
wish she was best
she's around for too long all these
people walk away you've been famous
forever walk away like
eventually everybody they're just gonna
figure it out now fallon's on an apology
door because
apology torque because of the blackface
like is he well he was like he had to go
around and apologize a million times for
like
they're going to find the thing if you
don't go away
you got it you got to have a good run
and when you have a good run you step
back and you go okay
i'm still gonna do my thing but like i'm
not i mean there's only a few jobs in
entertainment right right
so i think a lot of the cancer culture
[ __ ] is probably these [ __ ]
want those jobs
they're like how long is this [ __ ]
gonna be dancing i can dance with
hillary clinton
i could do the charleston with henry
kissinger whatever the [ __ ] she does out
there
did charles do this she does she goes
out there to the charleston she's got
war criminals
her and bush are jumping around i mean
right she was buddies with bush now
she's a
cia agent stephen paddock
and do not ask me for sources but
stephen stephen paddock
who's that he was the guy that shot up
the vegas
concert that was very tragic listen to
this
the only guy that saw stephen paddock
alive his name is jesus compost
he was a guard at mandalay bay he got
interviewed nowhere else you know where
he got interviewed in the beginning
ellen ellen really weird and then they
went on if you could find that clip
they went on with a weird like diagram
of how it happened and ellen's like
showing the people out
not like an emotional like how are you
feeling how are you holding up it was a
weird diagram of like and then he went
to the left and to the right
it was very strange to look what the
hell is going on
this is a daytime show which is the
paddock guy and
there's two guys the chubby guy is the
jesus guy and now ellen is doing a doc
thing of of how the shooting happened
look how she's got like an antenna from
someone's buick that she's popped out
and she's using it as a pointer
but why the hell is this happening on
like a daytime show where she did this
is weird where'd she get that pointer i
don't know she stole it off
she stole it off an intern's car why
wouldn't you just use your finger
like if that was you if it was your show
and [ __ ] yeah wouldn't you just point
yeah yeah this is also a giant uh screen
behind her so they could have just put
it on that screen
so but she's using this thing i find it
very strange i don't know why
those aren't real palm trees
i know that street though i know that
block of beverly hills that she is how
weird is that i don't know why they're
doing this on a daytime talk show let's
keep it running
look at it she's dressed like colonel
sanders not colonel sanders she's just
like sergeant pepper this guy looks like
a member of her staff
what kind of outfit is she wearing i
don't know she wears it where's those
weird like militant
lesbians that should tell uniform yeah
but that's an odd look with all those
buttons
like why do you have so many wrist
buttons it was given to her and langley
the only reason why you have that many
wrist buttons if you're looking at
clothes on somebody yeah look at her
look at her everyone says she looks so
friendly she looks yeah she looks
friendly
she does look very military yeah she's a
militant woman
with a very expensive watch she dealt
with a lot of discrimination when she
came out it was very sad but then she
joined the cia her house got broken into
while she was at home
really yeah yeah she got a dope place in
montecito
and said and then they broke in while
she was there yeah and those people are
still being tortured to this day
probably they're still in an underground
jail yeah she's feeding them to her
staff
she's like it's okay don't worry about
it because you did good
is that the guy the survivor he's the
guy who met paddock
she's holding on to him it's odd yeah
she's allowed to do that because she's a
woman but if there was a man holding
onto a woman's arm that long
it'd be rape
be a real problem yeah that's for sure
so weird man what a strange interview
man i mean
the whole situation was strange what a
strange thing they never really figured
out why that guy did that there was no
motive
he has a very little footprint online he
was a chick he was in the philippines
yeah he was he made a lot of money doing
that jamie's just what did you do
jamie knows you don't know you don't
believe what do you think that's what
they said well i don't know you tell me
what's going on
okay but you just made a noise like this
is [ __ ] professional gamblers
not that's a lot of professional
gamblers buddy not about playing video
poker
is that what he does yeah that's all he
did yeah he was an arms dealer no i
don't know that
but i just see the way i said it very
definitively
he was an arms dealer yeah he did have a
lot of [ __ ] guns
some it's just very strange and a lot of
times what happens is
you know just give him a check for 25 oh
well good for her
big ass check too like you won the lobby
that's good
yeah imagine if you won the lotto when
they gave you a check that big and it's
25 grand by the way after taxes that's
not even any money how about i put us
it's like nothing like [ __ ] how about
you give me some real money yeah
and not eight thousand dollars when we
would give people fifty thousand dollars
to win fear factor
yeah the government i think takes
sixteen yeah that's crazy
you get thirty four dude when you do
your first job in comedy you have to
join sag which is three thousand dollars
so a lot of times you're like negative
yeah you have to pay three grand to join
the screen actors guild yeah and then
you're fi i mean it's wild
well this what they're doing right now
in california taxes they're trying to
retroactively tax everybody
up to 16.8 percent which is hilarious
yeah it's crazy you're going back to
january
yeah you know i know you were living
here over the last seven months
assuming that your tax rate was what it
is and you budgeted for that but
no we're going to steal your money are
they going to be able to do that
i don't know they're proposing they're
saying 16.8 percent for top
earners yep and then it's going to be
high no matter what because it was 13
yeah and a lot of people will be paying
14. it's a lot of money to go to
to a state that doesn't manage money
well and doesn't seem to fix any of the
problems especially if you're that guy
that's got that multi-million dollar
house in front of [ __ ] tents
and you're like what am i doing yeah
what am i doing i work my [ __ ] ass
off 10 hours a day i come home exhausted
try to spend some quality time with my
family i'm dodging needles in my [ __ ]
i don't know if he's spending quality
time with the kid but he's still like
he's like i got
some hookers and coke and this is still
a problem he's like they don't want to
come over here and walk through tents
these women are professionals yeah i
don't know that that guy's coming home
to his kids they're getting
uber no he pays someone to watch the
kids yeah but no it's it's falling apart
here very quickly
i wonder what's going to happen like how
far can it fall apart because i would
have not
it can fall further okay it will fall
further but machu picchu there's no one
there
okay that's a good point yeah man all
these places
it's gonna be taken over by the tick
tock kids you already see it happening
that's why trump's trying to ban
tick-tock they're 16 years old they
literally
run la these 16-year-old kids they go to
that steakhouse boa
and they all walk around in bedazzle
jackets and and there's paparazzi
outside and these paparazzi their job
yeah
they go like as the world's burning
these kids are doing this the
paparazzi's job is to ask these kids
like what's going on and they're kids
and they're they literally have
responses like
a regular child would they'll be like
what's going on madison and she's like
i'm trying to get a car
and he's like all right right and it's
so
sick like this is that guy's life he's
got to follow around these
children at least used to follow around
sandra bullock now you're following
around
a kid who like does this there's one
dude that was a comic oh he's still a
comic but uh he was a tmz guy for a
while and he was uh
yes i know that guy met that guy good
dude good looking guy he was like one of
those tmz guys yeah very nice guy
i meet him at the airport all the time
sometimes it answers questions and
sometimes like bro
i get that it's tough for a fellow
comment and we're talking i'm like
he's like yeah i get it but but he was
cool like if i told him like
i'm not into it i'm so [ __ ] tired and
i'm not going to comment on my friend's
death
like one of them was anthony bourdain
yeah like right after anthony bourdain
died i'm like i can't man
i can't what a way to make a like i feel
bad for those guys you have to camp out
outside of a starbucks and interview 16
year olds you're like what's the drama
this week
they also know where you are somehow
they're stalking these kids
what do they get how do they get the
flight information like that's what i
wanted i don't know
no one's done that to me joe i don't
know i always want to know how they get
the flight information
i don't know i don't know what airline
you're on it's weird
yeah i don't know i don't know like you
must have someone inside the airline
they send them money or something like
that they must have some sort of uh
that's interesting so they
they so then they show up at lax at the
right time yeah not just lax like they
show up when you're getting
off the ls at the escalator like at
[ __ ]
you know the fourth terminal you know
when you're in terminal four and you're
coming down
they're there for you they're ready wow
weird see they're outside of the
restaurants in beverly hills
a lot of times like they're just [ __ ]
people that go
they know what restaurants they're going
to get like if you go they want yeah or
or or any of those and the food in a lot
i like craigs but a lot of those beverly
hills restaurants it's not good
well it's a scene it's a scene yeah it's
exactly what it is but the food is like
you go this is horrific like if you go
to nobu and malibu they don't let them
on the property
yeah so they're on the street yelling at
you they yell at you yeah yeah yeah
so there's like the parking lot yeah and
then there's the restaurant are you
gonna miss that stuff are you gonna miss
like the no board now
like the food like the sushi no no i eat
meat
i know i eat meat and i don't like fish
you don't like food it's okay
i eat it when there's no meat around
yeah my dad's friend owned the
steakhouse he said that he was fishing
his bike
because fish is perfectly good if
there's no meat yeah i like meat well
the good thing about fish is you could
eat it all day long and no one gets mad
at you
if you eat meat people think you're a
terrible person meanwhile there's plenty
of cows and we're sucking fish out of
the ocean in record numbers
but the ocean's going to be drained of
of sashimi yeah but no
you know what no no generation before us
ever worried about us so it's like i'm
going to eat the sashimi and the kids
can figure it out let the tick tock
[ __ ] figure out how to get more salmon
but there's no shortage of cattle like
you can get
broken isn't the problem that they fart
and then it causes methane i mean i know
that that was the case but then they did
an actual uh a survey see if you find
that
they did some sort of a satellite image
of the united states they found out that
the large majority of
methane release is coming from dumps and
coming from
yeah which is interesting of course it
does all that food and everything's
rotting and it's just going straight up
well yeah
all of those you know people criticize
me because it's political but
what's very interesting is like sugar
gets away with everything
yeah sugar is like a like there was a
comedian who did a great joke
it was baron vaughn and it was like he
goes cocaine and heroin look at sugar
and go [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
dude that's the real drug he's
everywhere yeah i mean that's the real
markets
yeah so i mean sugar is just so endemic
in our culture that
and it's not that political and it is
very addictive oh yeah really
shafir did this and uh big j elkerson a
few people
we did this slim fast challenge for like
two weeks and you read the slim fest
ingredients all sugar
yeah you're just drinking a chocolate
milkshake yeah it just doesn't have much
calories other than the sugar
right and it fills you up in some weird
way what do you got jamie what is that
research shows removing all livestock
and poultry from the u.s
alone would only reduce global
greenhouse gas emissions by
0.36 percent you
[ __ ] just relax if you don't eat those
cows
they die on their own and no one gets to
eat them right that's the problem
yeah so you got to eat the cows yeah
this idea that you're going to save the
world that was something that was
promoted by a lot of these [ __ ]
propaganda vegan movies
right that if you like greenhouse gases
are all coming from that no
no no look a lot of greenhouse gas is
coming from shipping produce folks
right it's unfortunate it's true agreed
there's a lot of problems with growing
things
like almonds that you're using so much
[ __ ] water to grow these things right
you drinking almond milk what's your
feeling on home
i drink almond milk what you're feeling
on whole milk i think
raw milk is probably good for you what's
wrong
it doesn't bother me non-homogenized
non-pasteurized where do you find that
you can only get it in some stores
it's kind it's kind of wrong i mean it's
like yeah it's like finding dmt
yeah that's what i was about to say i'm
like sometimes you'll bring up a product
i'm like how do you even get that
i was drinking raw milk for a while
because you could get it at the
supermarket i think you get it at whole
foods but it was good for literally like
two days
does it taste good it tastes great
interesting it's really thick
and like you drink it and it doesn't
make you feel like [ __ ] like there's
something about
regular milk which i love like milk and
cookies you give me a [ __ ] chocolate
chip cookie and a cold glass of milk
whoa yeah it's so good you dunk it in
are you a dunker do you dunk
i have dunked boa has a dessert where
it's those warm cookies and they're just
a little scoops no ice cream it's like
uh it's a problem
it's a very good real good very good
thing but when you drink regular milk
your stomach's like all right we can
deal with it right whatever
but whole milk it just kind of goes in
there because it has all the enzymes
it's not boiled down when your body is
drinking pasteurized homogenized milk
the idea is
it can stay on the shelf longer it could
feed more people it also lasts longer
keeps people from getting sick i get it
all that stuff's good
but the problem is that your body
doesn't know what that is
like that's boiled and dead there's no
enzymes in it
when you drink regular milk it's like
your body's like oh we know what to do
with this
this is raw milk this is milk it's not
this pad like pasteurization
exactly yeah okay yeah that's all yeah
and you don't [ __ ] with almond milk
well i've had it it's a little lighter
than whole milk yeah not milk
it's not it's nonsense it's a chalkiness
well it's some [ __ ] [ __ ] where you
you
take almonds and then you soak them
and then you get this murky water and
then you drink that and lie to yourself
and by the way most almond milk has
sugar in it like duncan
i love dunking and dad like dude almond
milk it's so healthy i go yeah
why don't you read how much sugar it is
per serving he's like 19
grams i go yeah 19 grams that's why it
tastes so good everybody lies you're
drinking a vanilla milkshake
well you go whitney's you go over
whitney's house when he has all these
weird plant-based things
but they're all kind of like weird like
plant-based chocolate pops and
chocolate almond milk and but she's very
thin because she she doesn't eat a lot
of those up a lot she well that's what
she does she has speed
yeah it's a good point she did all of
those things all of those things help
you know the needles every now and then
i'll call it she's got like nine needles
coming in i'm like is this covered
vaccination what's going on
she does the nad we both do nad and
reactions
um but yeah i mean but the plant-based
stuff never feels that healthy is she on
plant-based diets is that what she's
doing no she'll have meat every now and
then like i'll bring her food that has
meat in it and she probably eats like a
wolf
yeah she'll eat it i mean a lot of times
i try to bring her like an eggplant
parmesan or something that's like in her
wheelhouse yeah yeah she's uh she's dyed
her hair pink now like billy eilish
when did she do this she's recently i
mean she's like gone off the
she's probably losing her mom we need a
vaccine nicki glazer was talking about
shaving her head on twitter i had to
reach out to her yeah
did you yes are you like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
right now i'm doing it in solidarity for
my friend who has cancer by the way
there is no friend
yeah oh geez she's like going crazy yeah
people are having issues
she's coming on next week i texted her
and i'm like you what what is what are
you doing and she's
she's like oh i'm going crazy she's
she's in missouri with her family yeah
she's living with her family while this
is nikki's great man
she's in love she's great she's a
[ __ ] great comic she's
look at whitney's hair she's so crazy
yeah whitney's
really when he keeps getting younger
like she looks like she's 17 years old
because of the adrenochrome
yeah what's happening there where'd that
blue [ __ ] come from what is that
what is that who's this this is her
assistant and he shoots things at her
she knows how to stay around her
assistant's hilarious yeah he's very
fine together a very fun
girl yeah he just like i don't know
cracks eggs over her head or whatever i
don't know but it's good i mean
it works it's it's a fun dynamic she's
having a good time
yeah i she's one of those people that i
go man how does whitney function without
the store
which is probably what a lot of people
say about me right we'll also define
function
but i mean like yeah no of course like
some of us just
people assisting by shooting a potato
gun at her in her backyard let's not go
let's need that fix
i agree man i had to get out of l.a i
had to go to the desert side i couldn't
handle
the feeling every day that things were
disintegrating minute by minute and they
are
yeah that was wearing on me so i said
let me just go to a place where there's
just 80 year olds driving golf carts
yeah bob hope you just look at bob
hope's house it's nice joey diaz had a
really good point i think he's right
he's like before you leave joe robin you
gotta go down there and film that [ __ ]
you're gonna show these [ __ ]
they don't know they don't know yeah
they don't know
go down mel rose they don't know they
don't know what the [ __ ] dude i listen
to the episode he did with lee when they
talk about dissolving the church and was
like
that was a great [ __ ] episode man and
it was like emotional it was like
because that guy along with you helped
define a whole era of podcasting and
comedy and everything so it's like when
you hear him talk about
walking away from la and why he's doing
it and the family i mean it's a real
like
impactful thing don't tell joey yeah
what's going to happen he's just going
to attack one
winter in new jersey and i'm going to
call him up joey i bought you a house
yeah green i'm gonna make sure it's real
near
walking distance to good food yeah yeah
yeah i'm gonna buy them a house yeah
yeah yeah
buy them once i open up a comedy club
yeah you're hardcore you're like going
full
i'm gone you're doing it i'm gone well i
know you're gone but you're really doing
that
and everything [ __ ] doing everything
yeah listen it's exciting i need comedy
i agree also i feel like uh austin is a
fantastic artistic community there's a
lot of like
fantastic music yeah it's the live music
capital of the world
food is [ __ ] sensational very good
the people are cool as [ __ ]
i just felt like that's a good spot 100
i mean we all need comment i'm doing a
tent in long island in two weeks at
governor's day
they've set up a tent in the parking lot
and i'm doing it because one
cause like hey good for them why not
good for them
time to start little by little figuring
out like what this is gonna look like
good for them for just [ __ ] adapting
you know i like that these restaurants
are like
if you go down venice they're like
taking up the sidewalk yeah they're like
we were all supposed to shoot i don't
want to say what but me and a bunch of
other people
were supposed to shoot something for
netflix uh in august in la that never
happened that's so now it's like you
don't know what the hell is going to
happen with that
yeah um i um i was going to
try to do my next special uh right
around the new year
that was my plan and you had the garden
book get all these things oh yeah
i had a lot of [ __ ] booked but my plan
was to
make this mad run i was going to do
boston gardening madison square garden i
had all these theaters booked me and
chappelle were doing a bunch of dates
and the thing was to come into like
january february just [ __ ] coming in
hot
and do my next special and now it's like
part of me look i'm not happy that this
is happening for anybody that's sick or
anybody lost a business anybody but
you have to be able to adapt and look at
the bright side
so for me what i'm thinking is right now
is at the very least what i can do is
use this as an opportunity to examine
what i want to say in my act right
examine it instead of just doing bits
that i know are killing because i have a
lot of bits that i know are just
murdering
right and i'm like okay should i do that
bit how what is that is this how i feel
is this real like where where do i go
with this and then go
go forth once the year rolls over i
think around 20
21 january february that's
most likely if there's a possibility of
doing stand-up again
that's when it's going to open up
because they're talking about having
some sort of a vaccine
around december so well let's see but
yeah
yeah sure yeah i think it's gonna get to
a point we're gonna get to hurt immunity
a little quicker than we think
well you know i was talking to uh ron
funches yesterday and i was like ron
what if this is it
this is the this is how we live from now
on you could still go to the store
you could wear a mask right you could
still go to a restaurant wear a mask
like is this or what would we do right
would we eventually just start doing
stand-up again say [ __ ] it if you catch
it you catch it
it's a good question i don't know i i
think that
you can reach her immunity with this at
a lower percentage than a lot of other
things because we
they say that we have exposure to prior
previous corona viruses and that
you could maybe start reaching some
level herd of meaning around 20 to 30
percent as opposed to 60 percent
which would mean that new york already i
mean the new york kova cases are very
low
that's one of the reasons i'm doing that
tent is because they're very low right
now
yeah but la's skyrocketing la's
skyrocketing but no one cares
like everybody's out there is
skyrocketing it's the wrath of a
vengeful gods
i mean let's be very honest i mean do we
deserve to not
be no i i think it's skyrocketing
because it just went across country
it was just east to west everything cool
kind of starts in new york then it ends
up in la to get sold and get ruined and
get big and get ruined
so covet started in new york you know
it's one here just gives you zits
around everybody just uses covent
filters to block yours no one cares i
mean people are out in the outdoor
restaurants i mean it doesn't really
matter people are enjoying the
restaurants the outdoor restaurants but
i feel so bad for all the really good
restaurants that don't have an outlet
places like that i'm really i'm upset
nancy silverton's ppl
apl felix you like felix has an outsider
oh they do
oh that's wonderful they're whole
outside it's fantastic that's awesome
maybe i'll go there tonight they have a
next door restaurant that had this whole
outside area that you knocked out over
there
in the desert when you go to restaurant
it does you eat the food you like
chewing it you're like what the [ __ ] is
this
what kind of food today i don't know
what goes on i go to like seafood
restaurants after i start chewing
something i'm like i don't even know
what this is
i've no i there's one good one called
pacifica which is really good
but there's a lot of restaurants out
there in the desert where we go
something's wrong
so you just decided to go out there did
you previously have experience with tom
no but i was in a car and then the
people the riots started
so i i was in a car and the riot started
and i literally
instead of going back to my house
because i live right off sunset an
apartment right off sunset
instead of going back i just got on the
10 east that's right
never even been out there i just said i
put the clothes on my back
i said not swear to god instead of
getting under 10 east what am i gonna go
i look like a cop i look like a guy that
should be burned alive
for every sin that this country has
committed right right
no one would care my own parents would
be like he probably did something right
to deserve that
so i'm like i'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here because i get lit up immediately
um so i just started driving under 10
east i got an airbnb i took some dude
i'm like hey can i you know it was a
nice everybody
i just got out there and i'm like i
[ __ ] love it out here it's just
nice it's just quiet i know people have
like vacation spots
of course and then i just said to myself
i'm like if la's not going to be if i'm
not at the store
and i'm not doing anything i can drive
in to do podcasts
i can easily drive in how long did it
take you to get here
uh under two about two and it's like a
san diego
all the traffic is ventura freeway have
you ever thought about living down there
like la jolla
no no two i'm not a surfer
you know what i mean you don't have to
be a surfer i'm not here i came here to
do stand-up comedy
i came here to create things um i didn't
come here to
be a surfer i didn't come here to do
yoga i didn't come here to join a cult
i come here to do any of that i'm an
east coast guy east coast is where i was
born and raised like
which makes sense that you're in the
palm desert yeah because it should well
what are you going to do i'm not i can't
go
move back to new york get shot in the
face so i'm staying there until december
till the holidays and then i'll figure
out you know who knows we'll see what's
happening in the world
the violence rate in new york right now
awesome it's a little too much
it's a little too much so crazy it's a
lot and um listen how are they gonna
turn that back
it'll be turn around dude in five years
everything it's a cycle it'll it'll
bottom out a little bit
or or be done forever because bosnia
it'll be a cycle dude in five years a
bunch of rich kids will move in there
just like they moved in there in 2009
they'll start doing alternative comedy
dressing like [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] like flappers they'll
start tripping you know
and they'll just and that'll be the
resurgence of the city they'll they'll
they'll open a bunch of new coffee
houses in what used to be homeless
shelters
and it'll just and it's just a cycle but
what needs to happen now there's going
to be a lot of pain
yeah there's going to be a lot of
displacement of people and then i think
this could be the route to the city
getting cool again
to maybe younger artistic people coming
in architects doing cool [ __ ]
reimagining public spaces you know new
york needs to get shaken out of its tree
a little bit and so does la that's
what's happening
right i just don't want to be here for
it like maybe it'll get dirty and
dangerous again
it's going to get to the point where
maybe everything won't suck times square
will be like time square
yeah and people that move to new york
will will they'll be
you know listen if you know you could
get slashed on the way to the comedy
show you better kill
[Laughter]
you better make it work you have a lot
of attention you better make it work if
it's
safe and you and your friends are like
skipping down the street you don't you
don't ever feel that
you know pressure where is that other
song right
pressure is good yeah and and i think
that now you're going to get it you know
we'll see where do you think you're
going to wind up i don't know
tex is very interesting to me that's
very interesting i mean
the idea of that is very interesting i
put up the bat signal for everybody yeah
i mean that's very interesting to me i
mean i also think
uh you know i do like la but i don't
know what's gonna hap i do like it here
i mean they're
you know i don't know what i'm gonna do
i may manage you know i've talked about
managing logan paul's presidential
campaign i could always move back to do
that
um we're gonna have to talk to jake
though okay he's gonna be like roger
clinton
he's in trouble right now well there's a
few guns he's not trouble she's got a
few you got an arsenal he's like billy
carter he's got an arsenal list silly
beer
yeah there's always like a roger clinton
there's always a brother who you go
you take you just sit down was it an
arsenal thing or was it because he was
he was stealing things from the mall no
i think he was just walking around the
mall being
being what he does which is with a
camera and then i think
you know he left i think an ak-47 on his
hot tub like
leaned up against the hot tub i think
somebody ratted him out and then you
know did you show it on twitter or
something
yeah there was something on instagram or
something but dude
a guy like that with that kind of money
i say get more weapons get up gotta buy
a weapons lab
you should have a back coronavirus going
24 7. get anthrax
jake paul get anthrax who cares you're
going to need it when la falls
these are the only [ __ ] you know that
are going to be able to do anything
they're going to have arsenal's good
point yeah man why not
it's not a bad idea yeah but i don't
know like la's very weird because you're
you're like where do i fit in you know
without stand-up comedy or like i
podcast and that's
good and i try to make that as funny as
i can but then you look around a lot of
places l.a like i don't really fit in
with the actors
and i'm not really one of these kids
it's really like a social media guy
and then i'm not one of these com these
writers that you know tweet about global
warming and black lives matter all day
so you look you're like my community of
people which was the store
and the stand-up comedians are have now
been like dispersed
so it's like a weird like i'm like a man
without a country yeah i feel like that
too and i want to be adopted by one of
these like someone come
in here like one of these big youtubers
i don't care
anybody one of these guys that walk
around you know like high pistes and
these crazy shirts and everything just
i'll be one of those guys just
someone knocked on my door your own
thing well i mean
golf shirts and just screaming just just
polos just like this just ill-fitting
polos yeah
ill-fitting polos for the american
racist
polos are a weird choice pier like why
is it that that is like
the only thing i wear for dorks wear you
know what it is i i
i've always wanted to look like i've had
money and i've never
looked like it and there's a type of guy
that's from
a lot of them live in new york or long
island or boston by the way yes izod
yes and they wear these [ __ ] polos
and they have no [ __ ] money and
that's the kind of guy that i am where
it's like
i always want to look but they're always
sunburned
and they've always got like an
ill-fitting thing like the collards like
these collars all [ __ ] up
because i tumble dry it in the wash like
an animal
i look like a like a golf pro who's
failed at everything
his wife laughed like john daly's
brother yeah yeah i mean
but that's the look and when you have
the look you just honor the look the
izod
look i remember when i was a kid i have
fake eyes ons we couldn't afford
uh alligator okay so what was it you
have like an armadillo a [ __ ] thing
that you buy from like
you know some stupid departments yeah
and guys would glue
uh an alligator over it oh really
depressing
oh that's rough yeah well they would
fake it they made it out
but
but it's so funny like you figured it
out kids labels to kids are a big deal
like if you have off-brand sneakers on
like
one summer saved up for a versace shirt
and i bought this versace shirt it was
like this weird mesh material that
clings to your body
now here's now we can imagine there were
many problems with that right
because versace has european cut clothes
now even if i
you know were a small clothes [ __ ]
clothes no cut cut they're european
they're for dudes with like small
shoulders you know the you see dolce
gabbana like
they're just they're they're they're
women like they're hangers right
so i bought this versace shirt which was
like blue and mash and it was just a
night i mean
i look like grover or something like
cookie monster walking around
and then i just spilled something on it
and then i realized like designer
clothes you can't ever spill anything on
and ever
or you have to like throw it out like
those types of material
it just doesn't work and i'm like oh the
people that wear these don't eat
or when they eat they don't eat in a way
that gets things on them
or when they get things dirty they just
throw them throw them out get another
one they're crazy yeah they're wild
i've never been into fashion yeah i
never have either but i have been
fascinated by the whole
paris fashion show runway me too it's
interesting to the point where i've
actually like i remember when kanye west
was getting into that
and you know he was making his stuff and
have people wear it on runways right
i almost want to be there to see what
one of those things are like because i
bet
some of the people there are probably so
preposterous yes so weird well that's
like going out to dinner in l.a you see
these people walk into these restaurants
and it's kind of hilarious you're like
these people are
like a a meme i mean like they're not
even real
i'm like oh my god so that's what
fashion week is like i think i think
it's an entire business built on
[ __ ]
yeah it's like an entire business built
on like what do you think and like buzz
and all this crap like there's nothing
real about it other than
what's created as long as our business
is kind of like that too where it's like
there's no nuts and bolts and it's all
pretty much like
what set where's popular sentiment going
how much can we affect it how much can
we direct it
and then there's you know
eight-year-olds in pakistan that make
all the clothes
yes yes all these things
which is sad but they need to work
i mean we see what happens when you shut
down a country nobody works do we want
eight-year-old pakistan he's in antifa
no
work i wonder what's gonna happen with
uh american manufacturing i wonder if
there's gonna be a real shift
recognizing what a huge problem is
having all our medicine made in china
all like there's not a single phone
that's made here not a [ __ ] phone
single one
not a single one everybody has a phone
there's millions i wonder if this makes
us rethink all of that and that we gotta
be more i mean that would make sense
right because ninety percent of our
antibiotics are made in china yeah most
of our medications that's crazy
that's one of the things that i thought
was very interesting about trump
was that he was like you know listen
he's [ __ ] we're getting [ __ ] by
china they're [ __ ] us
he was right he was right but it's just
when he's
right about things those things become
wrong correct because people don't like
him that's what i'm saying about the
politicalization
whether that's word or not of
hydroxychloroquine yeah when shop got
the covid he took it the doctor asked
him what his political leanings are he's
like what
he's like a lot of people don't want to
take hydroxychloroquine because of trump
yeah and he's like is that what i should
take it was yesterday was getting
nervous you think it's like a history
test you're like
where do you stand on imperialism so i
was like wait what he was better off
just coughing he was like what are you
talking about yeah give me the [ __ ]
medication that works
that's crazy yeah there's a doctor uh
what was that if any doctor says this
helps anybody that doesn't want to take
it
to me is crazy but it's a strange one in
that so many people are against it but
it's like
it's like hold on a second there's a uh
an article what's that article that i
pulled up
um really recently about oh here it is
the key to defeating uh covid19 already
exists we need to start using it
this is a doctor who is a
legitimate scientist right so then
they're trying to figure out like why is
this person
it works from doctor professor professor
of epidemiology from yale school
of uh public health he's not a he's not
full of [ __ ] he's not full of [ __ ] he's
saying listen there's
real evidence to show that particularly
in the early stages of this disease
before it stops the virus from spreading
it's an it's a malaria disease that's
been used forever but
a doctor in new york told me it was like
the lazarus drug like people just
getting up and walking out of the hot
like like people literally that came in
with it if they used it early enough it
was really
good right but then you hear these
studies where people are saying no
in fact more people died when they're on
it like well what the [ __ ] is true what
is real
yeah i don't i mean that's when you just
have to kind of clock out and you go
let's
figure it out well is it because of is
it different stages of the disease where
it's not effective
is it different like is it old people it
doesn't work on but it works on young
people
what are the studies how are you doing
the studies who's doing the studies i
mean it's
it's all very difficult have you done
anything different
in terms of like taking care of yourself
i take vitamin d
how much i take vitamin d i think five
thousand i use a day that's right
i take vitamin d um yeah i started
starting
i started smoking because the cigarettes
they said help
oh there was an article i'm kidding i
didn't know what's happening every now
and then i have one one cigarette but i
don't smoke i don't smoke but
every now and then at night as a
as a it's a relaxing thing once in a
while not all the time
do you smoke cigars no i should you want
one right now
no okay really yeah i appreciate it
though i should install a whole box of
them mike binding
i know i don't need another habit very
good just start smoking cars i don't
have to smoke cigars all the time i know
i i have an addictive personality so
whatever i do i tend to do it a lot
guess what that's the problem that's the
problem that's why i got good at comedy
diaz talks about it like
got addicted to that you know that's the
whole thing is like you end up getting
addicted to
something so you better make sure that
it's something good but i i've been
trying to do
better things and you know swimming a
lot working you know working out things
like that
well have you ever talked like when uh
evolutionary biologists talk about
addictive personalities and obsessive
personalities obsessive behavior and
they say that you're actually
this is very controversial but they
think some of them think that you're
actually
tapping into a trait that would make you
get very successful at things like
hunting
for survival like you get obsessed at
something so you you want to perfect it
you want to be
you're obsessed by it so you become
better at it so you become more
successful so you survive
because you have food interesting yeah
which makes sense or sure
or combat or the things where you're
going to be able to figure out so that's
like a primary
trait that a lot of us have and he gets
hijacked by heroin
right he gets hijacked by gambling it's
hijacked by something horrible it gets
hijacked by jerking off
yeah wow that's what it is wow so you
would have been a hunter
mm-hmm yeah oh it's listen it makes 100
it does
it does i mean it's just it's crazy it's
like in the modern
world that that trait becomes sometimes
a liability well this in the modern
world there's so many
like the modern world is not natural
every [ __ ] thing that we do
is very recent everything this is
they're so unnatural like every the way
we said
yeah yeah well what we do for a living
has only been around for 100
not even 100 years right when there was
the first stand-up
i think it was the mafia started putting
putting these nightclubs together after
like vaudeville
like it was started those type of acts
they started putting a brick wall up
yeah but i think that was you know that
was it's all very recent it's
it's in the last century yeah in the
last 90 and
guys like us would have been the mc
right and it would have been like a
[ __ ]
go-go dancer and a guy playing drums yes
yeah that's all that [ __ ] we're
descendants of like uh you know
tent carnivals and circuses it is crazy
that one of the most
prominent art forms in the world which
is stand-up comedy
is literally within the last 100 years
yeah but a lot of
it you know yeah but like that's your
music
poetry you have to look at the
predecessor's tuesday like it was
probably in the middle ages it was a
court jester
right so there's always been somebody
goofing around and being funny
sometimes they did comedic plays
sometimes there there had to be a guy
in the town square yeah yelling at
storytellers
and podcasting is like we're essentially
it's it's like other than being a [ __ ]
or a hooker
it's like the oldest profession because
we're just talking sort of
but we're doing it in a new way where
people are doing other things and
they're getting entertained while
they're doing other things like right
now while you and i are yucking it up
yeah there's a guy who's running around
a lake
right and he's out there laughing his
ass off sweating and it distracts him
he looks down in his watch yeah yeah
yeah
it's true yeah yeah but it's just it's
so simple it's like we're just
recording things changed a lot of that
because like musicians changed too
because everything would have had been a
hundred percent live performance like
sure
if you play guitar or a harp or what
file or whatever the [ __ ] it would have
been well that's what i missed
i miss i love podcasting and i get to do
it and i
but i i do miss the live oh yeah
experience being in a
because everything has context live yeah
twitter all these things have no context
when i did the uh houston improv which
is the only date that i did over the
last uh
few months it was like i felt like i was
getting away with something
i was like right and then i realized i
kind of have like almost like a low-key
depression
right i'm not doing stand-up it's not
bad it's not but it's like
right this is what it is and this is i i
hate to tell you all you folks out there
regular people who do not kill if you do
not go on stage and kill you do not know
what that feels like it's a high it is
not just a high yeah it is one of the
biggest highs in all shows
it's a life affirmation when you and i
would do the main room at the [ __ ]
store and you get off stage and murder
it's great
and like you would hand it off to me and
nothing's better oh my god nothing's
better
it's like the feeling and there's a
feeling that i remember like going on
stage like when someone was coming off
like they would introduce you and they
would just crush
and you looked at their face and you got
to see like there's a face of a person
who just
crushed right like they just and i would
i would always say this like i feel bad
for people who don't know what it's like
to crush
yeah well it's also like you look at
actors and you know how fun could that
be
it's fun i'm sure it is but it's it
can't be anywhere near as fun
no can't be anyone you're as fun just in
the raw visceral reaction of people like
greg geraldo always used to say
like it's that visceral you know
feeling it's not so much it's not like
you're getting love
but it's like you're just this it's like
this weird almost
like god-like experience you're having
in terms of like
being able to take a room full of 300
people and bring them
with you on a journey yes and take them
from where they are
to a place where they're hysterically
laughing to chan it's like a chemical
reaction to change
people's i mean that's why i'm going to
go do it in a tent
you're giving him a drug yes like yeah
you're giving him a drug yeah and i'm
not gonna do a lot of those shows but i
said i'll do one let me see what it's
like i'm curious
as to what it's like and i i've [ __ ] on
them and
i and i and i still may after i do it
but like i want to see what it's like
to just do it in in in in the
circumstances it can be done right now
are you going to do one with bert those
driving things you were talking about
that i'm not
going to do i love him
but i'm not going to do i don't want to
entertain cars like you you sip people
in a parking lot i'm cool
when i start performing at dodge
durango's and listen god bless him
he's got a huge fan base a lot of people
doing it i think kafka did it
i just personally don't i feel like
that's way too
disconnected for me this is all personal
right
yeah everybody's going to figure like i
love podcasting i i try to be as funny
as i can he's crazy rants
and that gets a little bit out that i
need to get out yeah
i i would rather do that than perform in
front of cars yeah
i don't know man i i think i'm going to
maybe i'm going to think once i'll try
the car thing you got to try it all once
but bert's doing it all over the country
he's basically on a drive-through what i
love about burp was like they were like
we're shutting down comedies like no
we're not
yeah burt's like we're not yeah he just
got shoveled out there
but it's also it's you know that the
thing about covid
it does give you an opportunity if
you're a comic to sort of sit down and
rethink things
and also to really appreciate what it's
like
to do stand-up again yeah that's true
like when we did that weekend in houston
like
i did it with uh moses and uh
hinchcliffe and uh
when we came back we were like man i
missed that yeah my god that was fun
yeah i mean i know that i'm walking into
a situation where i might i might get
off stage and go oh [ __ ] this forever
because it's a rough you know it's going
to be different it's not going to be
thankful though but i'm going to be
thankful
we're going to have a lot of fun tickets
sold immediately and like
that we're putting more shows on and
then it's my home i from long island
right so i'm gonna have a lot of fun
there with the people that come out
and where i think because it's gonna be
a really great place to ease back in
because i'm gonna be able to do some
material go off the top my head
know that the crowd has a lot of shared
experiences with me because we all grew
up in the same place
it's kind of uh training wheels to to
kind of come back in and then hopefully
i'm hoping by this winter we're kind of
start revving up again
because we can't i mean what are we
gonna do well what do we do if
covid is like this next august
if we're all the way to next august and
still like this i think it's on the road
again
i think it is a certain time we're gonna
have to make that distinction because
like
at the end of the day how does the
economy survive how does the country
survive
without these things i mean sports is a
mental people need
sports they need to participate like
they need to watch sport like you can't
take all of this away
forever i mean there's all these freaks
listen i get the people that the masks
that are like coughing in elderly
people's faces no good
but on the other side you have these
people that are like these weird like
cat moms that are like wine drunk baking
bread on instagram it's like
honey we can't do this for 10 years
i know you're happy because you're this
weird freak that doesn't like leaving
anyway
people need to [ __ ] leave their homes
yeah they need to leave their homes and
there's not a lot of entertainment
coming down the pipe either
not a lot of movies being made no not a
lot of ways to entertain yourself and
these studios are trying to figure out
ways to film
these movies and and keep people safe
but it's hard man yeah
they're gonna quarantine everybody and
put in hotels and
it's difficult yeah and but that's why i
think eventually
you know new york uh covert rates are
very low i think that it's going to blow
through
i think there might be a little second
wave but i think eventually
the viruses weaken they weaken and they
disappear it happened in 1918 with the
spanish flu
they weaken and this will weaken yeah
why does the virus weaken
well you know it just i'm an
epidemiologist
and what you see is a lot of times the
virus
is just it goes into the hosts and then
eventually the virus is like ah
like what causes it is it the people
that just runs through it's just like a
picture
somebody that just [ __ ] everybody that
you they've just ran through
they moved to the next town right you
just [ __ ]
everybody and then you're like what am i
gonna do and then if you [ __ ] like 30
people by the time you [ __ ] the thirty
first place
you barely have a heart attack dust yeah
you gotta have a hard one so i think
this this fire's just
i mean i don't know i don't know exactly
how it happens but it does historically
happen it's happened
yeah historically i mean do you think
this is a different kind of disease
though
i think the big problem is the bigger
issue actually now is
is economic even though cove is a
massive issue i think the bigger issue
is
how are we gonna how are we gonna stop
28 million people from being evicted or
foreclosed on because they couldn't go
to jobs
the government literally shut down the
economy these people could not work so
through no fault of their own
they have a real problem here there's a
real like housing issue
not just that how about the businesses
that are closed down how do you restart
a business when you have no money
correct what do you do how do you get
going and does the government have money
to give these people loans
you know now get started again i mean i
think they have to do something whether
it's universal basic income i don't know
what they're going to do
but that economic issue is going to be
really really massive
it's so [ __ ] anxiety filled it is
it's like how does this end it's a great
movie in texas
that's where it ends it just ends in
taxes that we all have guns that we all
just sit on our porches all day waiting
for someone to come near us how often
have you shot a gun
a few times like all upstate new york i
should i mean i don't have a guy i
should get a guy i didn't think i'd need
a gun when i moved to l.a i didn't think
i'd have to sit by my i sit on my
balcony with a gun you know it seemed
relatively safe when i moved in people
were annoying but i didn't think they
were coming to kill me
i didn't think they were coming in my
windows to kill me but now that i've
now that i'm like yeah i should get a
gun yeah i think i texted you second
week of quarantine i'm like
i got a gun you're like yeah you're one
of them yeah you're one of my liberal
friends
i'm not a liberal friend but i was like
are you a centrist
i think i believe in pedophile cults and
lizard people i think that's centrist
i think that's in the center i'm on the
fence with lizard people but the
pedophile cults are real
they're all real i just don't care i
don't care
that's really my political option it's
like i i think
it's not most of it isn't real you're
making a lot of it real it's not
real walk away like it truly
yeah like the the like people that are
real activists
a lot of them have like a degree like
they're a lawyer or a doctor and then
they use
their skills to actually help people
right
and they give up really profitable
careers to do that [ __ ] right but dude
your twitter
[ __ ] posturing and your virtue
signaling it doesn't do anything
it's fake i know it's fake and there's
just more to life than red and blue
and republican or democrat and all these
[ __ ] are trying to kill you and
they're all [ __ ] losers
and they're all just i mean listen
they're more capable
like the all the [ __ ] that they've
pulled the cia all these people they're
just too good
they're good they've beat me they're
gonna win they're gonna win the cia is
gonna beat you
maybe you should join i don't know who
needs to hear i'd love to but i don't
know who needs to hear this
but like stop investing your emotional
all your emotions in your
your time and energy into this thing
like you would be so much better off if
you just found something you enjoyed and
did it
right but you don't want them taking
away your rights
and closing in on your email account
they're gonna do it anyway are they sure
don't take my rights send [ __ ] matter
they're gonna take them buy the gun do
whatever you got to do like
there there's no winning here do you
believe in a well-armed militia you
think that's necessary
yeah but look i mean you could yeah i'm
all for people having guns
but a militia like it seems like more
now than ever
the idea of forming a militia is in
people it's gonna happen it'll happen
there'll be skirmishes there'll be
violence in the street but it's like
that's what i was most worried about
with portland and seattle
yeah at the end of the day you know i
mean i don't know
you know this country's not designed for
massive reimagining that's sad to say
i can say it i'm a comedian it is what
it is but the reality is
it's just not it's going to disintegrate
like everything else that's ever [ __ ]
existed
on the planet and you just hope that it
the plane lands
slowly and doesn't nose dive into the
ground but the the best days are over
here
the bright like the the hopeful you know
we're going to the moon that's
that's done really you you don't think
so
i think we could be in a little bit of a
blip when we make a nice resurgence and
in a year and a half from now
everything's looking good i don't know i
think we just head into a dystopian
insane kind of like tech world where we
just all live on compute like reality
barely exists no it's a real problem
it's a dystopian world we're heading
into well the real problem is if
everything goes into like a ready player
one type situation where
whatever they can manufacture on a
computer with artificial reality is more
interesting
that's going to happen and listen most p
here's the problem most people
don't care they don't want these rights
they actually don't
you like them because you're like a
successful person most people don't give
a [ __ ] about their rights
they want pizza they want chicken wings
they want [ __ ] soda
they want cheap credit they want to go
on a cruise once a year
they don't give a [ __ ] about their
rights they don't care they want netflix
and they want you know
garlic knots and that's the that's what
it is and
you could pretend like america's just
not a country like freedom loving
there's a few of those people most
people are just like hey whatever and
they're the happiest people a lot of
those people i'm talking about
are actually the happier people they're
not trying to build an empire
they're not trying to succeed they just
enjoy like putting something warm and
doughy in their mouth
vegging out and [ __ ] waking up the
next day and go [ __ ] i'm here again
and and they're the happiest people they
like to get drunk and go boating that's
it they like to get [ __ ] up and go out
on the lake
go out on the lake and get railed up and
yeah
and it's fun what are you gonna sit
around all day worry about what darpa's
doing it's like
the [ __ ] kind of life is that
a burger it's over i mean enjoy it it's
the end
the end's not that bad as ends go
as things as ends go this end happens to
be hilarious and there's still food in
the food stores
yeah that's a good point as of right now
i like your optimism this is a good
end it's not a bad end it's not the
worst end
i want to see what happens when joe
biden gets into office
i want to sleep a lot he'll nap i don't
see what the speeches are like when he
forgets what he's talking about he's
gonna have no clue
kamala he'll run for return live for
he'll he'll
he'll live for a term he'll it's kamala
and if you
pronounce it wrong you're racist i call
her k-dog
no she she's gonna run he'll he'll do
one term and then she'll run i don't
think he'll run for a second term
he's already too old he'll he'll do one
term she'll come in again
no one will care about politics she'll
be yass queening all over the place if
he does
run for a second term he'll be in his
80s yeah he's not going to run for a
second term she'll
she'll run she knows that that's what
she's pumped but do you think they have
to think that through when they
when they run for president like if
you're 78 and you're barely hanging on
now
it's probably unspoken but i think that
that's probably i think why he picked
her
is because she's everybody's been vital
yeah she everybody's kind of comfortable
with her she's a centrist
she's a cop right she doesn't care
she'll put you right in jail
she'll put the cuffs on you the
government the larger power centers are
very happy with her
that she'll throw him in the vans she'll
brand ya thank you so much
she runs who's her vp god only knows i
mean someone else that shares her values
which are
here it is aesthetic political and a lot
of people requiring all americans to
wear masks
three months he says for three months he
was joined at briefing by his newly
named running mate
hmm let me hear it it's weird it's a
long
speech it says this i want to hear some
of it i just want to hear his voice
okay here it goes give me some when one
arrives
and what plans to be made for we talked
about significantly about the racial
disparities that exist
and how it is uh covert
19 is affecting the different races
differently
and uh we talked about the continued
lack of
uh ppe protective equipment and uh
testing capacity and the like but uh
and i've put out a comprehensive plan
over the last
three months on each of these things but
today
i want to talk about one thing very
straightforward
doesn't have anything to do with
democrats republicans or independents
it has to do with a single simple
proposition
every single american should
be wearing a mask when they're outside
what for the next three months at a
minimum
every governor should mandate
every governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing the estimates by the
experts are will save
over 40 000 lives
in the next three months 40 000 lives
that people act responsibly and uh
it's not about your rights it's about
your responsibilities
as an american that's a bad line that's
not a great line i i get what he's
saying
at least he got through that without
stumbling he seems to be getting better
they're
they're injecting him with something
they're just getting better yeah no
legit yeah they got an alpha brain on an
iv drip yeah
right into his dick hole he's going
slower now because remember he used to
be fast and you got bro
he doesn't have a stutter you know he's
always had like a bit of an issue
what's the thing it's like aren't we
like
i don't know i just it's so depressing
that these people rule us but then you
also go
who even wants this [ __ ] job and if
you if you're really talented and you
don't even want that job
who wants that [ __ ] job i mean look
at this one she's indian she's black she
doesn't know what she is she's
everything
best for their health their well-being
and for their families
that's what real leadership looks like
and when joe talks about his priorities
he knows and he cares about the fact
that we have as a nation
witnessed a hundred and sixty five
thousand people who just in the last
few months have died in our country we
know that those individuals represent
families loved ones grandparents parents
sisters and brothers aunts and uncles
sisters
people those are all people she could
have put in jail
she's so upset she because we could have
put handcuffs on all of those kids
out there fighting wildfires they could
have been working for a walmart for
10 cents an hour in the kamala harris
prison program
yeah you know what are you going to do
it's just it's just
wild that these are uh our choices trump
or this crew or this uh old fella but
that's what i mean it's like this is
kind of the
beginning of the she makes sense to me
as a vice president like
you know yeah get away from all the
prisons she makes all the right
people feel comfortable yeah she makes
all the right like all the people that
need
uh somebody in there that will you know
check the boxes
check all the boxes yeah and uh who's
that guy
i don't like him
20 who is he i don't know
what does donald trump say oh he's
wearing a mask yeah
we unite night in our effort defeat
invisible china virus
and many people say that it is patriotic
to wear a face mask when you can't
socially distance
there is nobody more patriotic than me
your favorite president yeah this is the
end
i mean this is the end this is out of
the movie you tweeted to bill maher
today what did he say he went off on
bill maher oh because bill maher did
that thing about it
he did a eulogy for me yeah yeah he said
he wouldn't he wouldn't get eulogy so he
gave him
trump was not happy about that oh my god
let me
did you see what he said that's so funny
i didn't see that yeah i got it in here
somewhere
it's it's actually pretty funny he uh
it's just funny that he spent so much
time thinking about this
um he goes uh his ego is the thing man
that's the thing that really
watched bill maher last night for the
first time in a long time he's totally
shot looks terrible exhausted
gone and weak if there was ever a good
reason
for no shutdown check out this jerk
he never had much going for him but
whatever he did have is missing in
action
wow what a crazy tweet
the suburban housewife will be voting
for me they want safety and are thrilled
that i
ended long the long running program
where low-income housing would invade
their neighborhood
biden would reinstall it in a bigger
form with cory booker in charge
i mean this is kind of just very
race-baiting stuff you know
yeah he's basically like somehow yeah i
mean this is real
coded stuff you know that's kind of ugly
that's what they call a dog whistle yeah
dog whistle is a new thing dog whistles
new and a lot of the things they say dog
whistles aren't
they're just people are talking but when
you say stuff like that where you're
like
invade use words like that you're like
low-income housing is invading your
neighborhood you're kind of like
housewives
we know what you're doing here yeah the
housewives we know ms-13 climbing in the
window low income housing you know
it's you know but that's what he's this
is what he's doing do you think he gets
advised to say these things do you think
these things are no i don't think
anyone's advising him i think he's all
him
that's what's crazy right he's a he's a
creature and a creation
of all of the cultural trends that his
supporters hate
which are hollywood and big tech well he
is a creation of those two things one of
the most wild things recently was the
the bubba thing with the nascar with the
yeah
the noose yeah like what he was saying
that nascar screwing up the lowest
ratings ever
and uh first of all they had the problem
getting rid of the flag like
i mean the confederate yeah the
confederate flag not only that the
ratings aren't low
yeah how about what he said to the fox
news anchor when he when they go well uh
you know who's done more for black
people than me and they're like lincoln
and he's like well that's debatable
yeah and then she goes well we're free
mr president because yeah you're free
like that's wild it's just
it's just wild he's a problem he's off
the cuff he's not thinking enough
everything about the comic con yeah
it's a narcissist on a level that any no
one's really ever seen that before
in public life at this level and it just
should like he's the worst guy
in a crisis this is the worst guy you
would never you wouldn't want a guy
leading a boy scout troop in a hurricane
during this like no
this is a guy that just belittles people
uh
vindictive blames people he doesn't take
responsibility for anything there's a
smallness to him and it's all very funny
yeah like it's all hilarious but when
you talk about leading an organization
there's probably a lot of issues
there's a lot of issues yeah look at
that the hair
his hair is called suspect
after trump hair complaints what i don't
even know what that means
what does that mean talking about how
much water comes out of a shower head
and then like dishwashers and [ __ ] and
like people make fun of him for that but
why didn't he shave his head
he'd look great he'd be free that hair
is so much of his thing dude
yeah it's it's chaos it's exactly the
hair is like his brain itself
also shower heads you can't take a
shower the water doesn't come out
you want to wash your hands the water
doesn't come out so what do you do
you just stand there longer you take a
shower longer because my hair
i don't know about you but it has to be
perfect perfect
he says perfect because my hair
i don't know about you but it has to be
perfect
that's madness yeah well that's what he
should be focusing on right now
so his hair should be focusing on the
hair
and delmar show bill maher looking gaunt
yeah bill maher looking gaunt
i mean it'll be interesting to see these
debates are they going to have debates
they're going to have some version i
think kamala is going to be like
i got this she's going to be good with
pence she's pretty good
and uh but him and uh biden are going to
be very interesting but i don't know how
many people are going to watch i mean i
think a lot of people will watch
depending on the format i wonder how
many they'll actually have i mean
they're not going to be able to
be in the same room the way they used to
be where remember when the hillary thing
was going on where he was circling
behind him absolutely creepy
wild and then you remember the thing
where he brought the five women to the
debate to accuse bill clinton's live
right now and there's
72 people watching it no this is the
white house
72 likes no it can't be 72 people
that means that's youtube suppressing
their views this is they're
about youtube this can't be periscope
can't be real white house is twitter
well why don't you click on it again and
see if it makes 73.
refresh your browser jamie's part of the
problem
you're part of the problem i want to
hear what he's saying let's see what
he's saying
what's he got you know 500 000
applications coming in going all over
the state nobody even knows where they
came from you saw what happened in new
york which was
a disaster with congresswoman uh
carolyn maloney it was uh
it was a basic disaster it's it's a male
in voting
and we can give you many other locations
on sites what has happened
is that's part of a big negotiation
that's a actually small part of a big
negotiation he likes to do this
yeah let's do this it's small this is
his hands
here's what i understand there's all the
complicated stuff he brings it in yeah
this and then that it's a master like
he's like a master communicator but he's
it's like he's not but he is it's like a
weird
thing i told you that was likes 12 000
people but still i just clicked on the
james
still 12 000 people like [ __ ] it's not
exactly
for sure we could go live on youtube and
have 125 million yeah
yeah that's so crazy i mean he is he is
uh
it's been a while it's very interesting
i wonder about the kids that are growing
up under him
like the young kids that have no idea
about politics except for trump
like they've never had any experience
with anybody else this is what they know
a president is and they're going to vote
for the first time when he's in office
yeah
this is 15 year olds or 15 when he's
elected president talks
and that's why a lot of those kids are
going to this just
tic-tac-y like dancing and nihilism and
just being like yeah nothing means
anything and
they're right it's also i mean imagine
being a kid during the formative
time of your life the world gets shut
down you're stuck at home and you can't
even see your friends
you can't go to school you got to do
school over a laptop it's crazy it's
weird it's crazy my kids go to school
over laptops and i've sat in the room
and watched and those teachers could
when
when no one's watching the teacher i
don't care they don't give a
[ __ ] right they're so bad they're so
apathetic yeah
some of them are great polish
i said that on my podcast the other day
i said abolish teachers
defund and abolish is that getting a lot
of press um
it's impossible no i tried to start a
movement it failed but i said if we're
gonna let people police themselves let
kids learn on their own abolish teachers
okay no cops no teachers yeah
what else i mean teachers have a much
worse track record than cops if you look
at the numbers well they don't get paid
as much as cops
well but still if cops were shooting as
many people as teachers were failing
i don't think it's that way i think
that's like teacher we would have to
make cops responsible for suicides too
then but here's the whole thing
teachers a lot of them are not doing a
good job yes but a lot of kids aren't
showing up
but if those those are the educational
suicides
i know but i'm saying that if if a lot
of a group
if we're going to broad brush a group i
like to do that
if we're going to broadbrush cops let's
broadbrush teachers get rid of them too
okay who else should we get rid of
garbage people take care of your own
garbage no we need them
we need them really when people don't
have a job
it's true how about that's where
universal basic income comes from
yeah get ready to get rid of cops
teachers firefighters
you never see a fire let's be honest i
see fires all the time no you don't oh
and they
evacuated three times they take care of
themselves the reality is
you never see a fire downtown in the
city these guys put the sirens on
they're going to a movie they're liars
sometimes they go down but they're white
supremacists
these firemen are white supremacists
they're about the black ones
multi-racial white supremacy endemic
white supremacy
they don't even know um yeah but i don't
know i mean there's no
there's there's very few good solutions
with coven with this it's like
we're gonna live in an imperfect world
we have to decide what version of an
imperfect world
is sustainable all right president yeah
you're the president president tim
dillon what do we do next
um what do we do next if you took over
right now
we'd have to do a universal basic income
for
six months we'd have to do an eviction
freeze probably where's the money come
from
um we print it like we've printed
everything else
yeah but you know how much money would
be involved in universal basic income
for like how many millions of americans
well
you could also do well it's a stimulus
they're doing it right now with the
stimulus right i think the bigger
problem is the eviction freeze you'd
have to freeze evictions
you've got to freeze that gotta freeze
down and mortgages as well mortgages
mortgages and rent yes
yeah um you know i would do that i think
that's the most
but for how long how long your freezer
for four months five months
six six you know and then then you would
have to kind of
open back up um you know i would put all
of
all the resources in energy there's
there's not a coordinated federal
response at corona it's all state
responses which i understand makes sense
to a certain degree because states are
dealing with different things but
there's been a lack of kind of a federal
i think
like targeted response of like here's
what we
hope happens here's what we get but
because i think right now people are
just living without the idea of hope
or the idea that something is going to
get better or reopen
and i think that like they need that and
that needs to be on a federal level like
the country needs to go
hey we're going to get moving again
we're going to be able to travel
internationally we're going to be able
to do all these things we used to do
here's what needs to happen first and
there doesn't seem to be a huge
you know push for that kind of clarity
my real fear
is the thing that we were talking about
earlier that businesses
are not going to have enough money to
reopen to reopen and that money won't be
available
so how do you get the economy back on
track well i think it's got to bottom
out probably and unfortunately you got
to protect vulnerable people but the
bottoming out
and i don't mean bottoming out
completely but the
real estate values being lowered uh all
of these things happening
you know will if it's going to be a
years long process i don't think it's
immediate i think it's years
and i think eventually what happens is
you know you have a situation where
because of economic turmoil you might
have
but yeah the businesses you're talking
about are probably [ __ ]
but those people might have a shot in
three years when rents are lower
and your cost of financing is is is
potentially
you know probably not lower but maybe if
we keep the cost of financing low i mean
that's the other thing
interest rates are going to creep up and
it's just going to it's going to cost
people a lot of
a lot more money to borrow money so much
of the economy's run on just this cheap
credit that we've had since
you know obama's you know you know and
shift and all those guys explain it
where it's just like
we're just it's a it's a credit card and
we're just basically borrowing money at
close to no interest and
businesses are expanding and people are
able to get cars and go on vacations and
get
mortgages when those interest rates
creep up i mean it's just a perfect
storm of problems
jesus damn it's a lot of problems trying
to end this on a happy note
i mean listen three o'clock i'm trying
to like let's let's wrap it up in the
house here's the happiness
okay it's over enjoy it
it's over enjoy it it's over enjoy it
meaning that it's not gonna end like
crap like listen
we're gonna limp through this somehow
we're gonna be broken and beaten and
battered but we're gonna get through it
we need a war with china we need another
911 what
i hope the people that run us are
thinking of those things and i
bet they are really yeah we need a war
with china
a war with china we need a false flag
that gets us into a war with china but a
war with china kills everybody it kills
a lot of people but the rest of the
people
uh will open up coffee shops
glow-in-the-dark coffee
hey it is what it is i mean there's no
good waste out of this i think we
probably need a prolonged war with china
jesus christ and here's the other thing
before we leave can i say this yeah
can i say this war with china thing oh
and i don't want that but we need it
it's true who's closer to get us in the
war with china joe biden or trump
i i think i think trump looks like it
but i mean i think no matter who wins we
just we're just gonna need a world
champion it could be a cold war it
doesn't have to be a hot war
could be a cold war oh cool fun cold war
cold war they build a thing we
build a thing oh okay yeah we need that
because the whole economy is fake we
need that
um here's the other thing derek chauvin
needs to get epstein's in prison oh
jesus and here's why
they're not they're not going to convict
him on murder too because there's no
it's going to be a hard time proving
intent with that body cam footage
so what about the body cam footage well
i mean i don't know if they can
the body cam footage shows that this you
know they're floyd in the car that he's
out i mean listen everything shelvin did
was disgusting
and and horrible and but i don't know if
you're going to be able to prove to a
jury that he
intended to kill this guy murder him or
he was
subduing um a suspect who was
resisting arrest i mean he wasn't he
wasn't resisting arrest not at that
moment but he was like
like he was like but listen when
someone's resisting arrest when they
stop resisting
you're supposed to stop leaning your
knee on everything you did was
indefensible i'm just saying that's
murder too then if he dies from that
did he intend to kill him this is what
that's the whole thing it's intent
so the reality is i'm not that's crazy
that's like if you stab someone but you
didn't intend to kill listen i'm just
saying he can't get off
he can knock it off he can't get out so
i agree so
who is that guy that was epstein's
roommate the guy with the muscles
oh yeah he needs to go room with him
that's right
he needs to go room with him more with
china the big cop with the dogs
that's what needs to happen yeah these
are the solutions folks you may not like
them but they're the solutions tim
dillon ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much there's the guy he's
got to kill that guy we got to move on
okay and then we got to invade it looks
like he's ready to go um thank you for
having me i appreciate it i love you
buddy i love you too thank you so much
for everything always always a pleasure
it's it's crazy that i walked in here
like i
i you know a little over a year ago and
i did this podcast and i ended up moving
it changed my whole [ __ ] life it was
amazing
well and you've done that for a lot of
people so thank you it's my pleasure
yeah
thank you so much that's one of my
proudest things one the things that
makes me most happy about this podcast
is that it helps people
thank you so much my pleasure brother i
appreciate it it's always a fun time
thank you
no different i love everybody thank you
bye let's not go to war
i want to get you in trouble at the end
you